this is jaco podcast number 95 with echo
Charles and me Jocko Willington good
evening echo good evening the President
of the United States of America
authorized by act of Congress July 9th
1918 takes pleasure in presenting the
Distinguished Service Cross to second
lieutenant Air Corps James
K Conkel United States Army Air Forces
for extraordinary heroism in connection
with military operations against an
armed enemy while serving as a pilot of
a p38 fighter airplane in the 400 and
first fighter squadron 370 a--the
Fighter Group 9th Air Force in aerial
combat against enemy forces on 16
September 1944 during an air mission
over Aiken Germany on this date while
flying as rear man in a squadron on an
armed reconnaissance mission lieutenant
Conkle noticed that his squadron was
about to be surprised by a vastly
superior force of enemy aircraft unable
to summon his leader on the radio he
alone unhesitatingly pulled away from
his formation and vigorously attacked
the enemy immediately destroying one of
his aircraft in doing so Lieutenant
Conkle placed himself in a position to
be attacked from rear and above when
this attack materialized many hits were
registered on his aircraft which caught
fire burning his face neck and hands
despite his burning plane and the
gunfire from enemy planes Lieutenant
kunkel continued his attack against the
vastly superior enemy force and
succeeded in destroying a second enemy
aircraft breaking off combat only when
forced to parachute to safety when his
left fuel tank exploded
second lieutenant kunkel 'he's
unquestionable valor in aerial combat is
in keeping with the highest traditions
of
military service and reflect great
credit upon himself the 9th Air Force
and the United States Army Air Forces so
that is a military citation for a
Distinguished Service Cross and this
pilot also flew missions just after
d-day including armed reconnaissance
flights and attacks on German trains and
vehicles and airfields and also this
pilot flew close air support missions to
help push Germany out of France and
drive Allied troops towards victory and
it is an absolute honor to have this
pilot this hero on the podcast with us
today mr. Jim Conkel sir thank you very
much for joining us it is great to have
you on and you know if that wasn't good
enough
I am also honored to welcome back to the
podcast Jim Conklin's friend fellow
pilot another American Hero
captain Charlie plum f4 phantom pilot
shot down on his 75th mission in Vietnam
War and spent six years as a prisoner of
war in Vietnam
captain Charlie plum sir welcome back to
the show
Thank You jucco nice to be back and for
those of you that haven't listened to
Captain plum the first time he came on
the podcast just stop now go to podcast
number 76 because that is a that is a
whole incredible story of his time in
captivity it's detailed in the book that
captain plum wrote which is called I'm
no hero
but go back and listen that and then you
can return and you can listen to this
podcast but it was interesting because
when we got done with that first podcast
and I was taking captain plumb to the to
the train station which is which is odd
in its own right to have the pilot to
riding a train I don't know if you'd
approve of that to have the captain on a
train but and he said hey you know I got
this buddy
you you you might want to talk to him
and he said you know he's a world war
two pilot a fighter pilot and you know
he's being a great guy to talk to and of
course I said yeah absolutely so it took
us a little bit of time but here we are
and this is also the first time we've
had more than one guest at one time on
the podcast and sitting amongst you two
my plan is to sit back and listen to you
to talk about whatever you want to talk
about I've heard some of the stories and
and actually interestingly the podcast
that just came out last week was about a
book called the men at Arnhem which
detailed the the British participation
in the in operation Market Garden which
started on September 17th 1944 and as I
was reading your citation if you noticed
that was September 16th 1944 that you
were that you were shot down and that's
that's right at the beginning or right
right before that that operation took
place that's really true and of course I
missed it
if I heard some very interesting stories
later on
I was picked up in a vac Hospital by the
first well the 1st Infantry Division
picked me out they saw my chute and came
out and got me and thank goodness it was
never leave anyone behind they didn't
leave me behind and I thank them
profusely but through the aback hospital
to a General Hospital and then a
hospital train to Paris
and the train was completely full of
casualties from the Arnheim operation so
I wasn't too good a shape at that time
to listen to the stories but later on in
the hospital in Paris I heard some real
horror stories about what went on up
there and being a 9th Air Force pilot we
were working with the ground troops and
we really appreciated what their their
problems were and the difficulties that
they had and we tried to help them in
every way that we could so that was a
there was a very trying time
so I guess before we get into all that
at any greater depth how did you end up
as a pilot what you know how did how did
you end up there in terms of where'd you
grow up and I know you grew up here in
in California no I was born in
Pennsylvania and New Kensington
Pennsylvania my father was was in the
steel business and in 1932 my dad passed
away from injuries that he had received
in the First World War and so we at that
time he had retired from his business
yet even though he was only 36 years old
at that time but we were coming to
California and in fact we were pretty
well packed and had closed the house and
the whole works I'm nine years old and
he went to the hospital in New York
instead and passed away and my mother
who didn't even drive an automobile at
that time I remember her asking me do
you want to go to California and I said
yes and she took some driving lessons
and bought a Chevy and we came to
California on route 66 when they were
building it
and so my mother prayed her way to
California I bet it fortune driver I bet
she wasn't the only one that was prayed
but even at night I can still remember
she was driving and in the mud of Texas
and I'm out Porsche so my mother was a
very courageous woman no doubt so he my
dad had been very interested in aviation
and I picked that up in fact he used to
do steel castings for curtiss-wright in
in Buffalo New York and we grew up there
and every every time we went on a trip
none 6 7 8 and 8 years old we go flying
Wow we don't fertilize someplace and so
I picked it up at that time and and
pursued it and then you you get out to
California and that's where you go
through high school and I'm not through
high school I ended up in Beverly Hills
High School and September 1939 as you
know the war started or just prior to
that I mean it was all the talk of
Europe and the possible or the war and I
decided that this is going to be my
senior year and if there's going to be a
war we're going to be in it one way or
another and so I went out and joined the
California Air National Guard they they
had a squadron that was based in
Griffith Park California and if we're
this is a bunch of World War one pilots
and we had some old biplanes Douglas oh
38 observation aircraft open cockpit and
some of the later ones had even had a
canopy or and
I really had been hanging around
airports my mother was very helpful she
this would be before I had a driver's
license she would take me out to the
local airports Grand Central Erika room
I'd spend the whole day Saturday out
there and sometimes you'd even get a
10-minute ride if anybody had any money
to buy gas with but coming back to the
guard I spent a year with them and it
was a very very interesting year these
fellows that were the pilots they were
all mostly combat pilots from World War
one and I said that their knee and and
listen to all the stories from that of
course my idea was I was going to be a
fighter pilot I had friends at Lockheed
and I knew about the p38 and I decided
that I wanted to fly a p38 and I wanted
to go to England and luckily it worked
out that way so what what year did you
transfer from the Air National Guard
into and how did you get a commission
did you get a commissions you have to go
to college you not have to go to college
at that time to get a commission to be a
pilot
actually the guard was federalized and
we went on maneuvers to Chehalis
Washington and we were attacking Fort
Fort Lewis and the guard
we were the attackers and we were up
there for three weeks on maneuvers well
while we were up there we got noticed
that the the air guard was going to be
federalized and drawn into active duty
and that I wasn't 18 years old yet so I
had to have permission were you already
a pilot at this Oh No
okay so I'm a gunner maybe go on
so but no I was in the armaments section
and it was run by a sergeant white and
sergeant white kind of took me under his
wing and I I got some pretty nice
assignments out of it I learned a lot I
got to fly in the backseat and I'd go
out on weekends you know we had duty
once a month in the guard but you could
go out on weekends and I'd worked at the
airport and Jenna that extra flight in
and the the pilots of the guard were if
they knew you were interested they would
take you under their wing so I got quite
a bit of flying time and as for a
seventh in your life you're 17 years old
I was just 17 in fact I was 16 when I
joined so but you know this cut into my
school not the academics because I
wanted to be a Air Force pilot you had
to be 21 you had to have two years of
college and in 1940-41 that this is
getting pretty tight to do when we
entered the war so I didn't really think
that I was going to graduate from
college so I wanted to get in the the
classes that would do me the most good
if I could become a an aviation cadet
and it it all had all worked out we in
the interesting thing was to me
in April I took some time off on school
and I went down got a job at North
American Aviation and I worked on the
first ten p-51s built and I think Steven
what's today on the line in fact one of
the original first ten is in the museum
Oshkosh so some place within that
airframe there's some of my work and
that was that would have been the summer
of 1941 September and I was going back
to school and I had become accustomed to
all that money I've been making at North
American we got 35 cents an hour when I
started there but you know 35 cents an
hour wasn't too bad because I worked
alongside people that had two or three
kids and they're supporting the whole
family on the thirty-five cents an hour
we had a little labor dispute at North
American and they raised it to 50 cents
so we were really rolling you know but
in September I would want to get back to
school but I enjoyed that income so I
went to Lockheed they had a graveyard
shift and I worked at 7th and Santa Fe
downtown Los Angeles Lockheed Aircraft
had taken over this big warehouse and
they were building the wings and the ant
Manoj for the p38 and they're also
building the wings for the Hudson bomber
which they had gotten this very large
contract from from the British and it I
was there when the war started actually
acted I was there the night that they
attacked Los Angeles and the whole place
was blacked out if you remember the
famous story of the air raid on Los
Angeles I don't remember that story well
he clearly actually I wasn't even close
to being born neither was my dad
so what happened when they attack Los
Angeles well I miss out on those the
probably the most logical story that I
ever heard was that a a navy PBY flew
over Los Angeles and somebody hits the
panic button and although the search
lights came on and you could hear an
aircraft in the background probably from
fort MacArthur or someplace like that
and the whole Lockheed plant was blacked
out so we sat there in the dark for
about three hours while they fought this
battle with with the unseen enemy and it
course made all of the newspapers it was
a big story
so anyway world war ii started as far as
the u.s. is concerned december 7th right
after that they they dropped the age
limit from 21 to 18 for the aviation
cadet program they dropped the the
two-year colleges requirement to a high
school and so I went down and signed up
with about 300,000 other guys they there
was that many people that wanted to be
pilots although they were fit Wow in
fact I was quite concerned I signed up
they that would have been in June I
waited until September before they
called me down to downtown Los Angeles
and swore me in as a private as a
duration as a cadet and thought well now
I'm on my way well then I went home and
waited another four or five months
before they called us up they were they
had so many people that and there was no
place to put them they were trying to
build Santa an Army Air Base which was
the induction
area four for cadets on the west coast
and River just overwhelmed with they
didn't even have the barracks to put
them in so eventually I got called up
and I went through in little less than
ten months through Santa Anna pre-flight
went up to Tulare California for primary
in Stearmans
to Tech's Rankin school in Texas been a
the aerobatic champion of the US and so
there was it was a fun school so they
said they they hired the best Civilian
Pilot and had him come out and train you
guys that's correct in fact Tex actually
owned that operation they they appointed
most of the primary was a private
enterprise they were set up by the Air
Force for cadet training in primary in
the primary basis and so you went
through but got about 60 hours I prove
this theorem on and we have behind us
our competitor but this aircraft is used
mainly on the East Coast we didn't see
many of them out California we had
Stearmans and Ryan's and the West Coast
got through primary went to basic now
we're on a military base in the I went
to a little more California and that was
one of the largest Air Force bases our
Army Air Corps bases and it's just one
final you can still see the hangars and
everything but final at L'Amour Naval
Air Station you can still see all the
hangers from from our old base Wow but
got through basic went down to Williams
field Arizona and that brought me closer
to the p38 most of the p38 came out of
Williams
just south of Phoenix and from there we
were on a fast track and we weren't
quite sure why we were on this big fast
track but all of a sudden we get 90 days
I got to fire the guns once in a p38
one gun and we had four 50s and the
twenty millimeter in the nose and they
let us fire one of the 50s all of a
sudden were on a train going to the East
Coast and we're heading for England well
when you when you said you wanted to fly
a p38 and yet you had worked on the
p-51s what was the deciding factor that
made you want to fly a p38 instead of a
p-51 the p38 was a high-altitude fighter
it was it was probably it was our first
real combat aircraft the p40 was a
stopgap airplane did very well p39
didn't do well at all the 38 was the
only high-performance airplane we had
the p-51 at the time that I worked on it
was a low altitude airplane you had an
Allison engine and anything above 11 to
12 thousand feet you were you're out of
power
so the 51 was going to be a low altitude
British used aircraft and that's what
they wanted extremely fast and they used
it for tactical work and so that smart I
wanted to be in their aerial combat I
wanted to be a fighter pilot and shoot
down a bunch of airplanes so so I stuck
with the 38 and of course I didn't
realize the British were putting the
Merlin engine in the p-51 about that
time we were gonna get the greatest
there to hear combat airplane of the war
but yeah I guess that's what threw me
off was because you know I always
thought of the p-51 as being as being
you know the best air-to-air combat
aircraft on the war but I didn't realize
that it had go didn't get there
immediately and it had to get there in
stages so that that that makes sense to
me now yeah whether they did common
stages and plus the fact that when they
did get the Merlin engine it went to the
8th Air Force and the Air Force had the
greatest Pio our group in the whole
world they they they they have access to
all the newspapers I got all the
publicity the p51 was the greatest
airplane in the whole world the p38 had
been soldiering from early 1942 in the
Pacific on to North Africa and in doing
well all the way and no matter what you
asked it to do what to do it so I was
still a p38 fan I got to England and I
had great interest in aerial combat
there was a fellow by the name of
screwball Berlin it was an RAF pilot and
he was one of the greatest deflection
shooting experts in in combat I've just
and he was the hero of Malta they are so
he said the greatest what deflection
deflection shooting which is what is
that that means that when your camera
when you're coming in on an aircraft if
you're on his tail you've got zero
deflection if he's in a turn now you've
got to move the note you're your aim
point out in front of that airplane got
it and you've got what they called a
hundred mill site which was forgotten
now I guess but it was about so many
inches four thousand feet and an radii
you'd say is your if you were an SI a
thirty degree turn you might put one
radii or radii on half in front of him
and it's all eyeball
90 degrees you're out maybe seven radii
way out here hmm and so that's
deflection shooting well this is before
we got the gyro sight which we never got
into the p38 but the fifty one's got the
gyro sight - computed that for you so
you'd put the the size of the airplane
would be put into the sight by a little
slide then that adjusted your site on
your reflector and so then you'd put the
Pipper right on the aircraft and the
sight would compute got it the the leads
necessary to hit it so anyway I've
studied those angles off didn't you know
an hour before you go to sleep after you
go to bed you'd you're doing
computations on how many radii lead from
what position whether you're going up or
going down or sideways or whichever
where you want to go but I'll sit for
air combat I get to England and all of a
sudden I'm in the ninth Air Force now
this is the mud Air Force and the
support of the ground troops and all
operations is usually a fairly low
element so you're calling them the mud
Air Force is that what you're is that
what you said yeah and that's just it
that's delineating that these guys are
working with the ground troops and
you're flying low and the dream of
aerial combat is not so much there right
that's right eight there forces of the
glamour or forces got all you guys must
have been all ears though I mean you
talked about screwball but but the RAF
pilots that had fought the Battle of
Britain I mean were you guys getting
lessons learned from them and and were
you were they actually directly teaching
you guys at all I they talked to us we
didn't have any formal instruction from
them but conversations and usually at
the bar at the O club or officer's club
wasn't called it
I got two good points the old RAF
sergeant who had flown in the Battle of
Britain told me that if you have a giri
on your tail do something violent it
doesn't make any difference what it is
just make sure it's violent and the
second thing was keep your eye on his
exhaust because that's the first
indication you're going to get of what's
what he's trying to do and I thought
those were two good points and I used
couple times
yeah the violent piece and you could
apply that to really many situations in
life where you know we see people and
they're they're in a bad position in
life they need to do something violent
to move out of that situation wait for
something to unfold that was not only
air combat yeah and that's interesting
about watching the exhaust because you'd
see a change of like a plume come out of
the exhaust or you see the exhaust cut
off and you'd know what type of maneuver
they were gonna do he's trying to pull a
fast one and yank the power off and you
overrun him and he shoots you down so
but the mud Air Force is a that came
along we began to realize just how much
help we were due there the ground forces
and and it was pretty primitive but I
I'm covering a lot of area here in the
big larell over the short time but you
know we we had we had no navigational
radio we can't have four channel VHF
that meant that usually we could talk
amongst the squadron but the word was
don't be an earache squadron don't talk
on the RT yeah they off I we had that
same philosophy and all my steel
platoons and SEAL task units stay off
the radio yeah and now you're trying you
know we're doing ground support they'd
give us coordinates on the chart now you
go
go out and find it with the time and
it's all eyeball so when you're
eyeballing the ground and you're looking
for ground targets you're wide open in
your six six o'clock position so so
would you fly with multiple people or
multiple aircraft so someone had the
duty of watching the rear yes we did and
in fact that's I got to duty several
times what we we did we usually flew as
a squadron sometimes we'd fly as Sakura
with three squadrons usually we try to
put up at least twelve aircraft as a
squadron max would be maybe four flights
of four sixteen and so to answer your
question about you know being attacked
from the rear and so forth and the six
o'clock the Germans developed the tactic
against the tactical aircraft is which
we were and they would they started
vectoring their fighters in with ground
control radar and your first indication
was all of a sudden you had a swarm of
enemy aircraft at your six o'clock and
in early August forty four one of our
sister groups p38 group ninth Air Force
lost a half a squadron it's just they
got hit and they were surprised and so
we thought well we better start we'd
better do something about that so we
started putting a couple experienced
people instead of putting your your
first mission fellow in the rear end
Purpleheart corner we called it let him
drag a long way we thought well let's
put somebody back there that's gonna
have a little experience anyway and
and so we we did that and I drew one of
the first missions back there and sure
enough it or they came and I spotted
them and it called the break I made the
break
I'm squadron kept long draw and the
break is you're saying hey I'm gonna
break off from the squadron right now or
someone needs to come with me or we need
to face this other issue over here we
got a bunch of enemy aircraft coming
that's what that's what calling the
break is call your break you know when
you call the break they whoever spotted
the aircraft leads the break because you
don't want to lose them yeah you can't
take you if you see them you got to keep
your eyeball on them or you're gonna
lose them and so you make you call the
break you make your break into him from
whatever position they're coming from
the squadron then will break with you
and so all aircraft are now turning into
the enemy and probably an experienced
air-to-air combat group that was just
the normal procedure our ninth Air Force
guys we didn't do much of this and so
when I'm called I called the break I
made the break and all of a sudden I'm
by myself
it's the quadrant kept on going and now
whether they didn't hear me or whatever
I have no idea so all I had was a couple
of FW 190s and a round circle sitting on
a flat wing and all that up 20
millimeters and we're doing that we got
into a pretty tight turn and all of a
sudden I lost him in the turn and I'm
looking at my six o'clock and you might
as well been facing backwards there's
been a lot easier but I turned around
front and in my gun sight here's the
depth W 190 I mean I'm on top of it and
and he apparently spotted me about the
same time I think I fired a burst at him
I'm not even sure but he did a flick
roll so quick that I literally he just
flicked rolled out of my teeth p30 it
wouldn't do that the earlier ones the
later ones had Hillier on boost and they
would actually could perform that fast
roll rate a roll so he he got away from
me
and I was the perfectly wonderful shot
positioned to shoot it down so that was
our first encounter and the second
encounter was the one where you read the
citation I made the break nobody came
with me and I had more than I could
handle when you before we get to that
one when you were doing close air
support for troops on the ground and you
had four radio nets that you could be on
would you be talking to the guys on the
ground
yes it's some some sometimes you could
you'd be under with the control now the
the ninth Air Force was mainly p-47s we
had one group of p53 54th and they had
been the pioneer group with the Merlin
power 51 but they ended up in the ninth
Air Force but usually they were used
with the 8th Air Force for the escort of
the Bombers but some of the majority and
the 9th Air Force was a big Air Force we
had a lot of fighter groups I've
forgotten now how many that we actually
have but most of them were p-47 47 was a
great aircraft for close support and we
had four groups of p-38s and in the
thing so most of the close support work
was done by the p-47s in a real max
effort we were used to clothes
deportment
the p-47 was very short ranged
thirty-eight we had a lot of range we
could carry a larger bomb load than
these of the 47 and the 51 actually a 38
could carry two two thousand pound bombs
that's four thousand pounds and that's
Europe and b17 country with that so we
couldn't always get them usually we
could find something thousand pounds but
normally we'd carry two five hundreds I
like the thousand because the bigger the
bang is the less chance you have to go
back and do it yeah and when you went
back to do it again they're waiting for
ya and so up until that point that was
kind of your primary mission and was
going in and hitting railway stations or
Fed munitions factories armed
reconnaissance anything that moved and
if you couldn't find anything you moved
you try to shoot the engines insulators
off the high tension lines so any
anything you could get we there was
there's no problem finding targets and
different from the 8th Air Force we were
over the target area in a relatively
short time so they were shooting at you
most of the time how long did you how
long did you arrive in England before
d-day actually happen just a short time
before the day and I've forgotten the
exact date that we did rive in England
and had you phone missions before d-day
snorted no so your first missions were
actually right and the 38th because they
were so easy to recognize in the air we
were assigned the channel we recruit top
cover for the channel all the shipping
and everything between England and the
beachhead and we at that time it became
very apparent that the reason we had
been rushed into through training into
England was
they anticipated heavy losses we
expected the Luftwaffe to really show
during the invasion they didn't I bet
you've read that there were just I think
they had two sorties over the beachhead
on d-day and we anticipated that there
would be a larger effort against the the
channel with all the shipping I mean you
could probably walk across the channel
with a number of ships they were there
this tremendous target the fog didn't
show up so most of the like my group the
CDA missions were pretty boring but when
you were when d-day was about to go I
mean it's every single person you guys
must have absolutely known that what you
were about to do was that was you know
gonna be the one of the most epic
undertakings of the modern history oh
yeah it was a hundred percent you guys
all knew that and it will every little
by Road in England as jammed with
equipment and you know it's funny coming
back to some of the things we hear today
about our country in 1940-41 I well 1940
I was helping to haleyss Washington and
we were flying there was a hole over 38
we had two brand-new airplanes from
North America no 47 had a thousand
horsepower great aircraft not worth a
damn in combat but we we knew that we
were again working with the with the
ground troops and we would fill little
paper sacks with them quite far with
flour
that was our bombing we attack them what
the bridge
throw toilet paper out and these little
sacks full of flour and if you drape
toilet paper over a bridge on the
squally River the infantry couldn't use
it anymore so they had to get across the
river some other way and mortars crossed
two by fours served as a mortar cavalry
on horses we got lost we had to go look
for him now that's in 1940 in June 44 as
far as you could see his american-made
equipment and everything not only what
we were carrying but we supplied the
British and everyone else and this
magnificent effort by this magnificent
country and you just it's unbelievable
when you think back just before d-day as
I say every every little Road was jammed
with stored equipment can't imagine this
- one of the island didn't sink no I
have actually on a recent podcast I was
talking about the fact that many of
American or at least as much of
America's victories in many cases have
to be attributed to our ability to
produce and make things and and
America's incredible ability to like you
said build such incredible equipment in
such a short amount of time it's it's
kinetic it really was and we switched
from isolation Henry Ford was an
isolationist as I understand and he
turns around and builds a bomber plant
is turning out six seven eight ten b-24s
a day yeah yeah so this fantastic effort
but we all stood together in those days
yeah when when I always read that for
d-day they they wanted troops not all
but they were looking for that they
brought a lot of troops that didn't have
any combat experience I don't think 5%
of the
people that hit the beaches have
experience you know it's funny I got in
trouble in Paris a few years out of yo
this is a good story
she was there and back but we were
dinner in Paris
d-day celebration and I made a mistake I
stood up and said to the people in the
room that the ground troops here of the
infantry all you people that landed on
d-day
I said d-day is your day it's not the
Air Force's day the missions we flew on
day J were what we've been doing for two
years out of England and it was there
was no better no worse but when you stop
and think those kids that hit that Beach
no experienced officers no experienced
in combat and so in my opinion and I'll
stand by it and I had a few people at
the dinner who objected to what I said
but d-day was the guys that hit the
beach we we supported them but we didn't
do much more than what we have been
doing day after day you know you can
talk about the 8th Air Force and the
heavy bombers and the fact that they're
their losses were heavier than total
marine loss in World War two so we we've
been hurt but d-day that belong to those
youngsters what was the because these
these guys were so you know we're
inexperienced when you were out at a pub
in England talking to these army guys
that were getting ready to go in what
were they just a hundred percent fired
up to go that's only because I can
imagine myself when I was 18 or 19 years
old I first was in the military he
you woulda told me I was going to do a
giant and fabious landing an epic and
fabious landing there would have been
just nothing but absolute motivation and
excitement from me because I was young
and stupid and didn't know any better we
were all young yeah I guess I guess at
some point young and stupid goes a long
way doesn't it well I story about that I
was I was at Camp Kilmer we were in fact
we thought we were gonna fly across to
England out of we expected air
transportation for they were a group of
about 18 pilots and I think we were set
to fly and all of a sudden they gave us
all this equipment and leggings and
backpacks and helmet and all this stuff
and kind of stuff makes pilots nervous
doesn't made nervous made damn fools I
nobody knew how to use this stuff and I
know I got the leggings on I know they
were from World War one they gave me
this backpack and and all of this gas
underwear and everything and they didn't
tell us how a packet and I went out
behind the barracks and there was a
clothesline back there and I got some
clothesline and I tied to stamp a cup
for clothesline and they gave me a
helmet and I never tried it on so that
not that evening get get ready and we
start marching down some tour to the
gates of the Camp Kilmer met Lotus on
trucks and world were getting on the
Queen Elizabeth
and you had to go down a pier and then
up a whole bunch of stairs to get into
the entrance of the ship and I had a p4
bag with all of my clothes everything
and I had a bottle of scotch in there
and I packed very carefully and I had a
portable radio and portable radios in
those days were like 36 inches long and
the bullet matters so I'm carrying this
thing and they gave me this damn helmet
but they didn't give me the interior of
it and so this damn without the inside
of it every time I took a step that was
coming down hitting me on the nose and
then bouncing back again we go up the
stairs and someplace along the line I
set that bag down too long and now I got
scotch before back and we we come to
where they're checking us in and there's
a full colonel army colonel and he says
my God we're gonna lose the war so there
you go we got people that don't know how
to wear their helmets pack their bags
filled with scotch no more so but when
you're when you're talking to guys
they're there they're ready to go and
big day commences Natan they just don't
you know they don't know they don't
understand what they're getting into yet
and and again maybe to the credit of the
planners they decided it's better to
have a bunch of guys that aren't really
a hundred percent sure of what to expect
than it is to have a bunch of people
that know what they're getting into and
know how hard this is going to be well
that's that's for in fact what I started
to say before I got off again you have
to watch me very carefully way down
there
we got out of the officer's club just
before we were going to take off for
England and there's quite a party going
and and there was a little spirit
flowing and if you in World War 2
barracks buildings where the club was
they had a mezzanine on the second floor
and then it's open in the centre and all
these damned fools from the airborne
were up on the second floor Yellin
Geronimo and jumping off and this one
kid broke his leg and so I've heard
about guys breaking their leg and then
going on to combat that's another story
[Laughter]
from my friend Charlotte plump what's
that what about oh brother
we got so many stories to tell you I was
on my way to combat on the aircraft
carrier Kitty Hawk we stopped in Hawaii
for our last hoorah and so we went out
and found some pubs and whatnot when I
had rented a little motor scooter you
know like a little Vespa alright and
that's gonna work out well so I'm
driving around Honolulu and I look back
and when I look forward I'm a bore
sighted on an 18-wheeler and so I so I
laid that the motor scooter on its side
and slid underneath the axle of this
truck and pinned my right ankle between
the frame and the motor scooter in the
truck well and so I you know I I came
out and dusted myself off I'm thinking
okay that I tried to walk you know I'm
not walking very well and so I go up to
the closest house and knock on the door
and say yeah you know I guess I need a
ride to the hospital went over to
Tripler possibly big Hospital in Hawaii
and in the dock there looks at me and he
takes an x-ray of my leg and you know it
was really funny when you see when you
see an x-ray of a broken part of your
body you know you
you're in disbelief you know you're like
wait how come this happen
you know you'd and denial and the guy
said okay report to wing Bravo floor
three
I said what's on Bravo three you said
it's all the other idiots that broke
their leg riding motor scooters in
Hawaii and sure enough all these
military guys in this military hospital
had broken their leg on motor scooters
and so I said I can't do that I'm a
fighter pilot you know I just to help
start the Top Gun school I got I gotta
get out of here and I gotta go win the
war you know and and it I'll never
forget this doctor his name is Jensen
dr. Jensen said son take my advice you
can get into war in six months or so
after your leg heals and so what guy
said I can't do that I got to go back to
the ship ISA you said you can't ride
around on a ship with a broken leg I
said no an aircraft carrier we've got
Hospital as an x-ray machines and all
this good stuff we got doctors and
Surgeons and all this stuff I know I
can't let you do that you know we report
to all the other characters that broke
their legs no no I can't do that and so
I find all right I'm arguing with this
doctors without ranked me by about three
ranks and I said tell you what let me
call the ship I'll let you talk to our
flight surgeon and he can assure you
that I'll be okay by going back to the
ship because I got to go to the war so I
I call the ship well of course the
flight surgeon out getting drunk too you
know so he wasn't there and in fact the
only one in sick bay on that ship was a
was a corpsman like a third-class
corpsman okay and he doesn't know what
he's doing and but I'd say okay I'm
whispering to the guys okay that tell
tell this doctor that you're in charge
of the hospital and that it's okay for
me to come back so sure enough you know
he does what I say he does a doctor
so so I get a cab I got this cast on now
from my press from my waist all the way
up down on my toe got a big toes I mean
I
my ankle you know not not the rest of my
leg but I got this 20 pound cast on and
so I got these crutches and I crutch up
the gangway you know and the request
nation come aboard and the the OD says
permission granted and and and I hobble
my way into the sickbay okay here's the
same third-class corpsman
sitting there and he didn't know what
he's doing and he doesn't sign me in or
anything he says you know go to the
officers quiet room that we got one of
those in sickbay
and so I crushed my way back to this
quiet room and I I am exhausted I'm
totally and this leg is starting to
swell inside the cast and I'm in pain
and so I just flopped down in this in
this rack okay in the quiet room well
the next thing I hear is the engines of
a ship starting up and we're about to
leave now meanwhile my squadron buddies
you know wanting to leave no man behind
says where's Charlie they went back on
the beach searching for me for the last
place they saw me was disappearing
towards Diamond Head on a Vespa and so
they look all over for me and come back
and report that I'm AWOL
okay hi miss ship's movement alright
okay so so I wake up on and then I know
what's happening I get you know I gotta
tell somebody I'm here nobody else I'm
here I mean the third-class corpsman he
didn't sign me and he didn't know who I
was
okay so you know you know maybe squeeze
bottles you know in a hospital room and
it's supposed to some squeezing on this
bottle trying to attract a nurse or
something you know it's in there squeeze
squeeze squeeze I finally looked up then
the hose from the bottle was cuttin I
would just squeeze in air so I get my
crotch shot which is the only thing I
can move I'm paralyzed and I'm banging
on the hatch you know and I finally
attracted attention to this sailor and I
say you'd better go up to the ready room
and squadron 114 and you better tell him
up there that I'm down here well it
wasn't probably two minutes later the
commanding officer stand in the doorway
all right
and he is not at he said I've had 17
pilots I said and now I got 16 he said
he said first of all I said what are
they telling you when are you gonna be
ready to fly again I said six weeks well
you know weeks months I kind of got that
confused and he said you're going home
I'm gonna get a replacement pilot to you
oh no please please please let me stay I
gonna stay with the squadron you know I
gotta be with the troops in all plays
and so now you're going home
oh please be I said okay skipper what if
I you need you need a pilot from the
squadron to run the the maintenance on
Cuba point in Philippines you know a
pilot stand behind it for battle damages
stuff you know I'll take care and I'll
run those troops and for you I can do
that on a crutch and so he said okay so
he let me he let me off in the
Philippines and well the rest of the
squadron you know went to war the first
line period they went help there and and
I'm correcting my way around the
Philippines with a you know I added that
I had probably six or eight chiefs and a
hundred mechanics you know working these
airplanes well and so they would send
these airplanes back to me but I didn't
have any way to test them but the army a
trip or hospital had not taken my wing
so they they had not given me a damn
so I told me I couldn't fly well I
you know I got so I talked the doctor
there at Subic Bay to put on a walking
cast okay so I got a little cast and so
I can you know I'm qualified to test
these airplanes I can do this and so the
problem was first of all I couldn't get
into the airplane because my cast was
too big to go into that tow hole and so
I haven't my crew fork lift me up and
into the airplane my second problem was
I couldn't use my right foot to push the
right rudder
and this is uh this is kind of a nose
wheel steering airplane in the f4 where
you got to be able to push the rudder
just
dear so I would I'd go out and test
these airplanes and I come back and land
that at Cuba point in the Philippines
and instead of making that they say okay
you're you're cleared right hand turn
couldn't make it right hand turn
I made three left-hand turns together so
the the squadron finally came back and
and I got back with them got my little
cast off and I started flying missions
but until the day I was shot down I was
still limping on that ankle and I was
really afraid with a diet in the prison
camp but that was never going to heal
but you know as luck and fate would have
it it healed up fine and so you know it
but yeah that that's my story of get
breaking my leg on the way to combat
yeah thanks for bringing that up Jim
you know let's let's do we're talking
about now we're talking about getting
shot down you know you're ending up in a
prison camp let's you you were about to
get to the to the to the engagement
where you actually did get shot down you
want to talk through that one a little
bit further Jim and just give us some
details on that well sure
some of the details are not original but
back to the Purple Heart coroner you
spot them coming in again and this time
there were two different gaggles
that I could see and the gaggle is a
word that we use for the Germans because
they didn't fly real tight formation
they kind of they were just there was
that was that intentional yes it must
have been because they were you know the
German pilots are sharp bahi yeah but I
would guess especially in Germans are
generally orderly people so you'd think
they'd want to fly tight formations but
I guess if you think about it from a
from like even from a basic camouflage
perspective when you see things in a
pattern it stands out more so maybe they
did that to break up their pattern a
little bit well I would assume laughs
because they were very effective
and you know some of these boys you run
into where had been at it for a long
time and but as I saw them coming in and
was referred to them as I said it's a
gaggle I picked the one closest and
broke into it made the call that I was
making the break and broke and just as I
broke somebody got a shot at me and I
got hit back in the after part of the
fuselage and I I finally had a little
fire going and I'm sure I did but as I
made my first pass through them I lined
up and if you could get the p-38 nose on
a target those four 50s in that twenty
millimeter were devastated and so many
rounds a 50 Cal which you have we
usually carried 400 rounds per gun and
130 rounds of 20 millimeter and we
arranged our triggers so that you we we
wanted to fire them all at the same time
we didn't carry any tracer yet we put
five traces in at about 25 rounds
remaining so that you knew you were you
had to have something to go home on that
red start conserving your ammunition and
so I got a line on a clear shot I fired
at him but I don't I didn't know what
the results were because all of a sudden
I'm in the middle of us of a firestorm a
literal firestorm inside your cabin
inside your cockpit no or just still
outside the plane outside the aircraft
there were there were lots of targets
and apparently I went through them
really at this late date in my story
it's how much I really remember about
this I heard stories later which I'll
get to
it seemed like it went on forever and
finally I'm on the tail of a one-night
he I saw I saw some I knew I was
involved with 190s
but I saw a couple 109 someplace in my
peripheral vision so there there were
other aircraft involved and they're all
apparently they're all with me I didn't
know it at the time but we made a number
of passes I was very concerned about the
amount of ammunition you know if you
hold the power button down you're going
to be out in about 20 seconds so I was
very concerned about using all my
ammunition so I was trying to fire very
short bursts and we go round and round
and we're going up and down and I've got
on the tail of a 190 again I'm right up
on top of them when the p38 through your
gun sight you could also see your two
top fifties and it looked like I had
those two fifties right around the
rudder post is this 190 and out of the
corner of my eye I see these flashes out
on my wing tip and they're coming up the
wingtip and didn't closer closer and
this is milliseconds and he hit me right
in in by the the left engine and we had
an air air scoop that came in through
the leading edge of the wing and into
the cockpit by your left knee which is
our only cold air into the p38 and again
I see this in the peripheral vision now
I'm concentrating on the guy in front of
me I see this air vent making like a
blowtorch and so this is not good
again my next memory is I'm out falling
through a cloud I don't remember our
emergency reliefs was above us p38 had
actually had windows and you crank them
up on both sides and the only way you
could get them down is to hit the little
release and then crank them down and so
we have a top hatch which was our escape
hatch which is about this wide and you
have a backpack hewed on and all the
equipment and I I don't know I don't
remember releasing anything pulling the
safety belt or the shoulder harnesses
but this is unlike you know Charlie
you're you know the modern rigs where
you pull the ejection handle me this is
all stuff I mean in a modern aircraft
you pull the ejection handle and you're
getting shot out of the aircraft all
automatic oh that's all you do yeah we
didn't have to think about anything we
weren't smart as these guys so this is
all stuff you manually had to do
unbuckle yourself get and open up the
hatch or the window and and get all that
done while the plane is burning and and
then you have to get out and that's kind
of when you come back into consciousness
oh you did that either instinctively or
at some point while all this mayhem was
going on that's right
I don't really say I don't remember even
reaching up above for the to pull away
the top hatch well I was just out
floating down to I knew the clouds for
around 5,000 feet because we've been
yo-yo and up and down during this time
and also just at one more point on a
ejection sheet a modern ejection seat
you come out your parachute opens
automatically right yes so you're you're
still in a ripcord scenario all right
where you're gonna have to make this in
parachute open so you say well you say
you're floating down you're actually
falling down
20 miles per hour towards the earth
somewhat like that so anyway I come out
the bottom of the cloud and I'm facing
up and I thought well I better turn over
so I I turned over and I can remember
distinctly watching the ground and I
thought I was behind German lines
because we were at Aachen Germany and I
had just knew that I was and we were
east of Aachen and I knew where
approximately where this bite started
and I didn't think it'd have gotten any
better about going west so I figured we
were all of different territory and so
we we've been told to not pull your
ripcord at altitude get down
it was Europe you're a lot less of
target lore you can get so I rolled over
and fell actually just fell face down
and watch the ground come up when it
looked like it was pretty close I pulled
a rip cord and this is your first time
parachuting or did you guys do any
parachuting in preparation for this no
okay yeah that's interesting
having haven't jumped out of at least a
decent number of airplanes this is not
something you want to do for the first
time but anyway the ripcord work and I
remember thinking well you know I got to
be ready to move when I get down so i
unbuckled the tool or straps on this the
shoe and I got him unbuckled and I had a
45 in the shoulder holster I got the 45
out and I'm trying to it to get
around in the chamber and I dropped him
I didn't realize my hands were burned
and so I'm not sure how I got the chute
buckles off and so I must have been
pretty low when I pulled a rip cord
because
just instantaneously there's I came down
in a red brick building and it had a
courtyard and a tree in the middle of
the courtyard and I could if I could
find the building I'd recognize that
today and my shoot caught in this little
tree and I jerked to a stop and I'm
probably six inches off the off the deck
and I remember doing that but then I
don't remember for a period and I kept
thinking it's getting dark and I thought
oh god I didn't you know where have I
been
and I'm going down what I was like a
little hedgerow and I had my 45 and I
saw these guys down in this ditch boy I
thought they were German and I saw they
had a net on their helmet and our guys
had net on the helmet now I've threw my
hands up through the 45 over my shoulder
never saw it again
but it was first Infantry Division and
they had seen my shoot and I came down
between the German positions and first
Infantry Division and what had happened
and I found this all later they first
infantry we were trying to take Aachen
you know we started this is
mid-september to try to take off and we
didn't get often until early November
but we actually took to town and the
first infantry had pushed up throwing on
the night of the 15th had pushed up and
taken this little area where I came down
it was a little town called the Ellen
door which was a suburb of Aachen and
they were having trouble holding it and
so they were getting ready to pull back
and they saw my shoot and they guys came
out and
picked me up took me to a vac Hospital
but before they did that they took me in
and into an area and I was in the
command post and I met a full colonel
and I found out later who he was he was
the commander of the 16th Infantry
Regiment and he he said he asked me if
you wanted dinner and I said I don't
know what I said anyway I apparently sat
down and had dinner with him right with
him and I do remember going outside this
area and throwing him up so I knew I had
eaten something but they put me in a two
and a half ton truck and where they put
the the stretchers they put him in
between the what are the side gates and
I there was some Germans in there and
some Americans and me and they hauled us
backmarker they took me through what I
found out later was the 45th back
hospital and they treated me there but I
right at that moment I don't remember
too much about all this going on except
I thought it was getting dark so I
thought I'd been on the ground for quite
a while and I found out later that my
eyes were had been pretty flash burns in
my face and hands and everything and I
was I couldn't see for a couple of days
so apparently I was having my eyes were
swelling shut or something and I'm I I
think it's getting dark
but they hauled the end of the the
hospital and I was very fortunate they
had a doctor there who either had
developed or was using a new technique
on burns and they took me in they off
this operating room and it was colder
than hell and I'm vibrating like blazes
and they start picking
like this and kind of drive me crazy and
what it was they developed this new
technique where they picked this all the
burn areas out to get it off there so
you heal from from the inside out and as
I went back to the the hospital system
they used me as a demonstration to these
kids that have been caught in tanks and
badly burned much worse than I was and
they were telling him that look what we
did here look how quickly he's healing
meeting me using this technique and so
apparently I was one of the very first
that they had ever used this on but when
we we were put on this train the
hospital trained and taken to the
American Hospital in Paris and they haul
me in there and this guy comes up to me
he says hell I know you he says we
picked you up and his name was Walter
Leonard Scott he was a with the 1st
Infantry Division Company C and he was
the second lieutenant and he became my
friend he stayed with me for quite a
while and he had witnessed almost all of
this operation as we yo-yoed around the
area why he was seeing a good part and
then he told me a lot about what
happened they they told me that they
estimated there were 20 and 20 enemy
aircraft
then that somehow or other that story
has stuck with with my story I don't I
don't know what there were I mean he he
actually was well I got most of my
information about what had gone on so we
we went through the hospital chain and
you know was it was he in the hospital
for
he'd been injured as well oh he we get
to England and he's telling me a little
bit about infantry life and he had
landed with the first entry Division in
North Africa he went all through North
Africa and what to Sicily and he had
been very badly wounded in Sicily and
they he and another officer had manned
an ANA tank gun in some big operation in
Sicily and the two of them stayed with
this anti-tank gun when everybody else
had departed and anyway he had received
a Distinguished Service Cross and that
was the first time I ever heard the term
Distinguished Service Cross and so now
I'm starting he started in 42 and he
went through North Africa Sicily he went
to England he made d-day and I said well
how come you're still a second
lieutenant we we hadn't been in we were
sent to England they they took us to the
Netley Hospital which was this gigantic
hospital right outside of Southampton
that had been built in the Boer Wars
something like that big looked like a
castle and so we hadn't been in there
two hours in this cute little nurse
shows up with a class a uniform for
Leonard Scott and Scott was gone I mean
we didn't see him for 10 days so I
figured it's Leonard Scott was probably
a person lieutenant four or five times
it sounds like from the cute nurse it
might have been worth it but you know we
we were quite close for just a few weeks
and for years and years and years I
tried to find Leonard Scott I knew that
he made it through the war I knew that
he'd gotten off separated from active
duty and at Fort Lewis and he was from
The Dalles Oregon and I tried to find
him and about a year ago my wife sat
down at the computer and in a matter of
a couple hours she finds his to sit of
his two daughters and he passed it had
gone through Korea went back on active
duty went through Korea he was god this
Distinguished Service Cross he had the
Purple Heart was seven clusters juice
and he had been hit he said he made the
d-day landing and in 20 minutes he was
on a landing craft on his way back to
England we've gotten hit that quickly on
and then he the day after I was shot
down he got hit again and he went back
after we separated he went back to the
1st Infantry Division Company C and it's
funny coming up to more recent times I
built a number III used to build and
we're still build airport facilities but
I used to build Air Cargo buildings and
so forth and lease them to the airlines
and I did a lot of work with Flying
Tigers and I knew Bob Prescott pretty
well who was the president of Tigers and
they
Wayne Hoffman who was the chairman of
the board the Tigers so tell us a little
bit about the Flying Tigers if people
don't know the Flying Tigers is an
airline a cargo airline that was sold to
Federal Express that is now part of
Federal Express and Tigers was named
because Bob Prescott he was president of
Tigers had flown with the Flying Tiger
organization in China
one of the original Flying Tigers and
right after the war he started a little
airline and called it Flying Tigers and
it became a gigantic - air Cardinal
facility and they were flying all over
the world and so I started building
facilities and wheeshing to him and so
the new Bob and new Wayne Hoffman were
well and I knew that Wayne Hoffman had
been on in the Army and then today in
the infantry but that's and we never
talked about him and Wayne's wife wrote
a book and she took all of Wayne's
letters that he had written home from
Europe during the war and put them in
this book and so they gave me a book and
I read it and I come to September 16
Wayne Hoffman is in Ellen Dorf Germany
in the first part of the Siegfried line
five o'clock in the evening in his
letter to his wife he said a very short
letter he said I'm in Ellen door and
there's an air battle going on above us
and we did talking that was me
and here we've been French a number of
years and we'd never really talked about
it and he was Company D or the 16th
regiment heard Scott was Company C of
the 16th regiment
and we never put all this together
that's so it's amazing what comes out
and I found out that two of the people
that are on the German side that I've
been involved with currently major Boris
they this is a long story I don't know
how far you want to go with you we go as
long as you want to talk they major
Boris allow go back and step I heard
from a gentleman in Holland and they had
some information about my airplane and
this gentleman had written several big
historical books and he lived in in that
little area where Belgium and Holland
and Germany all come together and he had
found like five hundred wrecks aircraft
wrecks in this area and traced it down
in history and and recorded it and they
came up with a p38 in Elmendorf Germany
and so they figured out and found that
it was my airplane and they found it in
1997 and so anyway in a series of steps
I didn't they get in contact with me and
he had studied that that air warfare in
that area and was writing another book
about that and he still you wanted to
talk to me about it and we did but
unfortunately he passed away but very
early he was a young man and so I I
never got a souvenir from the wreck of
my airplane is there someplace waiting
for me if I can find it but he told me
that he
he came up with two names that he had
read this book by call well there's a
story called the the war diary of JG 26
the yellow nose
Abbeville boys the yellow nose aircraft
and they he had written on scepter 16 he
had the story about attacking the three
370th group and the the Germans claimed
for p38 had been shot down and that
wasn't true I was the only one that lost
they actually attacked the group after
my engagement with him they finally got
their act together I guess and attacked
the group and didn't do too well but
like 20 minutes 30 minutes later
whatever the time of them but he figured
out that one of two people had shot me
down one fellow was was major Boris
major Boris had shot down his first
victory was in 1939 he shot down a
Spitfire he had if he got me I was his
42nd victory Wow the other guy was a now
followed by the name of Keith Mila and
he if he got me I would have been his
82nd so these guys were not beginners
and so all this informations dribbling
in over the last sixty years so by the
time I find out about Boris and the
Luftwaffe there they've died so I've
never got a chance to talk with them but
through Scott we found Scott's daughter
is a very famous interior decorator in
San Francisco and so we're gonna get
together with her and she said that her
father passed away a very early a
baby was in these fifties but so all of
this keeps coming in we keep hearing
more and more you find something
accidentally beyond Earth two
interesting stories there Jim but you
haven't told us about the nurse helping
you with your clothes all the nurse this
is a g-rated podcast most of the time
coke and you know bleep summer go down
there were some lovely nurses I think we
all know what these gals were just
unbelievable how they took care of you
no it's actually a you know we've read
some books on the podcast where there
wasn't nurses that were over in France
and they were receiving guys right off
the front lines yeah well they they had
me on this 45th and I wake up and I'm
hearing all of this big bang and going
on the forty-fifth hospitals is here and
there's right behind that here there's a
100 + v + 5 artillery firing over the
hospital and they took me to from there
I went to the hospital the General
Hospital in in Brian Brussels
no not processed were there oh man
mastery and I left there one day and
then the next day after I left beat v1
rocket they flew right into the side of
the hospital of me and I have pictures
of it that I took this is later my
second tour through the hospital which
is another story but so that that was a
big tragedy
they had killed a number of the people
is one of
Ward's so and those those were nurses if
I knew how long did it take you to
recover and did you fly again or was
that was being shot down and wounded was
at the end of the war for you know well
it was in combat really I went through
the hospital chain and I was released in
England went back I was going through
Paris
and you know with the hospitals would
collect the uniforms I they took all my
flying jacket and everything was burned
from the wreck so it's all they stripped
you down and throw it all away and so
now I'm in a hospital in England and
they're gonna let release me and I'm
going back to my squadron I'm ready to
fly this is in November and my burns had
healed pretty well and so they give me a
uniform to wear and I don't know how
many guys how many times that sky
whoever's uniform it was it been hit but
there was also a bunch of holes in it
and I found a hat and so I had no money
and so I'm I'm treating my way back I
went to London and then I got a flight
to Paris and I got to Paris and so I
decided well I'm in Paris and I'm on my
way back for squadron I'm gonna see
something so I went down to the Lido
Club and I used to like and I'd still
like to dance but I like swing and so
I'm in the Lido Club and and they have
this pretty little gal singing some
French tunes and then they wanna so we
we had quite a night and so I left early
and I'm figuring on where I'm gonna
I'm walking down the Avenue and here
comes a gaggle like the end of of guys
with Pink's on and the green jerseys and
everything
damn here comes my battle jacket my
pants these are all friends of mine and
there were Mike they were staying at the
Claridge hotel right next to the Lido so
all of a sudden I'm better dressed I
borrowed some money and we enjoyed Paris
and then as you get back to the squadron
went back to the squadron with them and
they had transportation so I went back
with them and I'm there for a god I've
walked in everybody's glad to see me and
and they say yeah we just got a brand
new p38 in right from Ireland just came
through it's yours
and it boy it was a beauty so I'm all
ready to start flying again and doc Berg
who was our flight he comes to me and he
says Jimmy says I don't like the way
you're walking and I said well I'm just
a little bit sore but everything's fine
and he said well we're going over this
we were at a 70 or a 78 at that time I'm
Florence Belgium he says we'll go over
to shawl around and just check you out
and so I go over to the hospital a child
along with him and the next thing you
knew I got a cast from here down to my
rear end and they x-rayed me and and I
had a broken back that they hadn't
treated so back to the hospital and so
we I went through that went back to 3rd
military well they had them what they
did is they have a central medical
section and they run all the pilots
through there and then they would
determine what happens
so I kept saying well I want to go back
to the squadron and so they said okay
we're going to you got your cast and
they took the big cast off and put a
small one on and said we're gonna send
you to England for at least 30 days
through a black house
well black houses is where they run by
the Red Cross
and mainly work for Bomber groups if the
bomber crew had we're getting a little
nervous or something they'd send him
down for a week or so and so they sent
me to this black house and the first
thing I get in trouble with with the Red
Cross is this fighter pilots like to
talk about combat and flying the bomber
guys didn't want to have any thing to do
with that kind of conversation so the
Red Cross gets upset with me and they
tell me I got to keep my mouth shut and
I said well fine I'll keep my mouth shut
but I'm gonna do this give me a set of
orders and I'll go off to some base cuz
I'm I can walk so I I had a little plan
you used to get your flying time your
pay you had to fly four hours a month so
I would I'd write a set of orders and
said that I just temporary duty and four
hours of flying time so I go off to some
base and with with a small cast on and
I'd say I walked in and say here's my
orders I need four hours flying time so
they didn't range and I'd fly for four
hours and and go back to the flak house
and a couple days later I'd write some
more orders and go someplace else so I
got to apply a number of aircraft while
I was there and so pretty soon my thirty
days are over I go back to third mental
medical and they send me back to the
squadron
you know got Berg was not happy to see
me at all and at that time I got orders
to report to general spots headquarters
in in Paris and he said they didn't tell
me what I was going down there for and
some Colonel came came to the squadron
he's also assigned on this same deal
same set of orders and so we go down to
Paris together and his name was in
Toledo and he ended up two or three star
general
he had decorations from his neck down to
his waist already and so I get down to
Paris and I'm gonna get the
Distinguished Service Cross well outside
of Leonard Scott who never really told
me what the Distinguished Service Cross
was I wasn't sure what we were about to
get and anyway we we got that and went
back to the squadron again thinking
everything at least is pretty close to
right and Berg says you're going home
and so that was the end of that except
I'm grounded and that's why I'm going
home I'm grounded so I had I had all
these records with me and you know we
officers then I suppose they still do
you carried your own records with you so
I'm going home grounded now I got my
records well I still have those records
and they're in a footlocker down in my
hangar nobody else ever got I got home
and took a medical and passed it and so
I'm back on flying duty the wars still
on looks like we could might be going to
out to the Pacific to make the invasion
of Japan implying the latest p-51d 51 H
got married
and with my childhood sweetheart who I
met when she was 15 and everything is
right in the world and and Harry Truman
dropped the bomb and ruined a perfectly
good war is just about it I stayed in
til 1948 and I got to apply our first
jets and had a wonderful time had a
wonderful experience learned a heck of a
lot got to do things that would have
never happened to me if we hadn't have
gotten involved in all of this worked
out great and so how did you two end up
meeting well I had this old antique
airplane and I was looking for a hangar
for this airplane and Jim was building
hangars at the time and this little
bitty airport up in the valley above
Santa Barbara called sentian Eze and he
helped me build a hangar and it was kind
of interesting the attraction and if in
fact my wife brought this up me said she
said you know you're gonna have three
generations of warriors talking on these
telephones yeah I mean today on this
podcast you got Jim Cole on 30 years
later you got Charlie plumb 30 years
later you got jack o wink he said and
there's a certain attraction with
warriors I don't know what it is with
our brains you know but there's some
kind of a kind of a magnetism or
something you just got identify with uh
guys that have been in combat and so
even though they're I don't know there
are probably a hundred pilots on this
Airport Jim and ice kind of hit it off
without even knowing our history and the
more we got to know each other this is
like 20 years ago the more we got to
know each other the more similar
philosophies of life you know we had and
and so it's not just our flying because
Jim still flies course I still fly and
of course I've got an old antique
airplane that
from his training days and but more than
that the technology has changed that the
enemy has changed from world war two to
Vietnam to Iraq you know a that but that
but the camaraderie of military guys you
know they're just something and and a
lot of stuff that you talk about Jocko
in your podcast and in your books just
the you know the fact that we're all
accountable we're responsible not just
for our lives but for our buddies and
there's something about that that
community of warriors that that really
connects so that's how Jim and I got
started he built a hangar for me and and
I moved in my wife made a a man cave out
of it and so so I mean that that's we
are we're new in this yeah that was we
we joked about that on the first time
you were on the podcast that that you
had the ultimate man cave and you know I
kind of threw that out there but now
that I've been here it is actually
factually true that you do have the
ultimate man cave and I'm gonna take a
gulp and take a bunch of pictures maybe
we can do a video like a little tour of
it and just show everyone kind of what
this is all about and and all the I mean
the history that you have here and the
pictures and the photographs and and the
you know pieces of aircraft and
everything else is it's it's phenomenal
to look at and you know is interesting
so when I got here you know we're
walking around and Jim's hangar as a few
hangars down and you know you said hey
Jim wants to show you something and and
I said oh well you know okay you know I
don't really have any idea what it was
so we we get out and we walk from your
hangar and we're walking down towards
Jim Jim's hangar and you know we shake
hands and I meet Jim for the first time
and he says you know I want to show you
something and I say okay you know neat
and he goes it's a picture and I said oh
awesome and I have no idea what to
expect and he says it's someone you know
and I said okay well that narrows it
down but I don't know
you know I don't know who I have in
common you know with Jim or I don't know
I had no idea no idea who this was over
this picture was gonna be so we go to
Jim's mancave which is an each equally
impressive and an awesome
you know hangar with you know his
personal effects and pictures and models
and parts of aircraft and everything
else and he walks into a corner and and
he picks up a picture and he hands me
this picture and the picture immediately
I know who it is and it's it's this
second lieutenant from the Marine Corps
it's a picture of a young
chinese-american second lieutenant from
the Marine Corps and it it's it's
currently who I about in podcast number
53 colder than hell and I went kind of
off about him a little bit I talked
about him a lot because if you remember
from this particular podcast and from
that particular book this was at the
Chosin Reservoir and and this second
lieutenant curtly
he was while these guys are engaged in
in just intense continuous combat in
order to lead his men he fashioned a
fluorescent orange vest out of some
signaling material and we're out of some
parachute material or something he made
this vest for himself so that he would
be completely visible to all of his men
now that also means he's obviously
completely visible to the enemy as well
but that was what kind of a leader that
this guy was you look I'm gonna take
extra risk but I'm where I'm gonna make
this happen I'm in charge you're gonna
know where it where I am and you can
follow me through whatever and it's an
incredible story of of heroism so that's
the picture that Jim puts in front of me
is this picture of of currently and I
kind of look at him and I you know and
and it turns out that you that you knew
curtly yes Kirk was a good friend a dear
friend and quite a story and I had
tremendous respect for him I
I have tremendous respect for his
principles to the last day of the before
he died and fond memories yeah it was
it's an interesting story too because
that's another thing that we talked
about wasn't part of that what he did at
one point in that book and I don't
remember it specifically but he
basically dresses someone down in the
middle of a firefight for not giving him
you're not calling him sir or not
calling him lieutenant and you know I'm
kind of saying hey guys you know you
need to think about when the right time
to do this is but as you said he was an
extremely principled person and kept
those principles at all times well you
know he he led a group of Marines
through the night to relieve Fox Company
which is quite a well-known story in the
Marine Corps
paka company was holding a hill that
commanded the escape route for the whole
Chosun reservoir group army Marine Corps
and they they were under heavy attack
and the idea was to get down and support
them and curtly I could speak three or
four different dialects of Chinese and
so he's leading these he's of the scout
who was actually reading the whole
contingent of Marines through the night
through heavy snow terrible terrible
conditions and actually as they came
across of Chinese sentries troops he
would talk to them in Chinese and they
got the whole whole contingent got
through and they made it in time they
relieved Fox Company tremendous story
yeah it is unbelievable story and
unbelievable that you handed that
picture to me and and that you knew him
I mean that's just this phenomenal
phenomenal situation was there anything
Charlie that when when you were on last
time was there anything
you know I know we talked for a few
hours I think yeah we did yeah
was there any major things that as you
listen to it again that you said to
yourself you know what I should I should
talk about this as well not that nothing
that which specifically comes to mind
but now that you know that the three
Warriors are here together you know I
think we should talk a little bit about
philosophies of combat and the fears
that we faced because they think you
know to the general public the vast
majority of your listeners and viewers
are not in the military and so you know
my my thought is well how do they relate
oh it's interesting history you know I
love the history of the greater
generation and I love your history as
well and the things that are going on -
you know today that the guys at the
point of the of the spear but what does
that mean to the you know to the average
guy you know who's never been in the
military there are some principles I
believe that the three of us learned in
combat that can that's transferable I
think to to all challenges of life you
know the the just you know the fact that
you face your fears you know you step
into them into the box and and Jim bit
it and you've done it though where you
you could have run the other way you
know you you could have quit you could
have checked out but you know I mean all
three of us felt like that we had a duty
a duty to our country to duty to our
Brotherhood and so we you know picked up
the you know picked up the baton and
continued on and so you know to me
that's sort of the important part the
part that you can you can transfer more
than just the military history that we
all have the the philosophy of meeting
challenges because I'm convinced you
know you can you can be in just as much
of a of a challenge in your life you
don't have to be flying jet airplanes or
running around the SEAL Teams you can
face challenges when a person is
diagnosed with cancer or loses a child
that matter gets cut out of your land on
the freeway you have a choice and and
the choice that you make it certainly
depends on not only your character but
then it also transmitted into the
outcome of the character that you
continue to be in life and so while
we're you know 30 60 years apart in our
in our generations here our philosophies
of life and the warrior psyche continues
and so I'm just really really proud to
be a part of this and proud to be with
you Jocko and of course with you Jim
Jim and I see each other probably a
couple times a month we get together we
have dinner our wives you know cook good
meals and we go fly sometimes and and
there's a certain silent language I
think between us that we don't even have
to talk to each other and yet we
understand what what's going on you know
where we're coming from in the the
accountability that that we share just
because of the experiences that we've
had I got asked a question the other day
I was working with a company as actually
known as Nick with a company I was doing
a speech and I was doing some Q&A at the
end and a guy asked me how do you define
character and how do you build it and
I'd actually never been asked this
question before and quite frankly I
hadn't really thought about it very much
and and this guy had to thought about it
and I talked to him afterwards and it
was something that he it was why he
really wanted to hear me talk because he
wanted to get my perspective on this and
I answered the question like this I said
you know for me character is not a very
complex thing for me
character is you do what's right
you do what's right you do the right
thing that's what you do and if you do
the right thing regardless of what the
consequences are whether that that
represents character and so then how do
you build character it's a beautiful
thing because it's the same thing if you
want to build character you do the right
thing you do the right thing for
yourself you do the right thing for your
family you do the right thing for your
the people that you know you do the
right thing for your community you do
the right thing for your country that's
what you do and now on an individual
level
those things are hard things often right
if those are hard things you have to
make the right decisions you have to
live a disciplined life those build
character those little things that you
do on a daily basis to make yourself
better to improve your health to improve
your your situation in life you're doing
those things they're hard to do and when
you do those things they build your
character and ultimately they lead to
your character being a good character as
opposed to a bad one but I've never been
asked that question before and I thought
that the simplicity of it is pretty
clear when you think about it you know
when you think about the people that you
know you know when I think about the the
people that I worked for in the military
or that work for me up or down the chain
of command what what is it that made
them people that cuz you know there's
bad care you know we can't sit here and
pretend like everybody of that just
because you did in the military you've
got great character that's absolutely
not true but what about those people and
I you know I thought through this in in
three seconds as this guy asked me this
question you know I thought to myself
well what about the guys that I know
that have good character that I look to
and say yeah this this person I trust
you know without question what kind of
person is that
that's the person that you know is gonna
do the right thing all the time
regardless of the consequences and a
couple of things about that first of all
it isn't easy in fact usually the right
thing is the toughest thing you know
it's that it's the hard decision the
second thing is it doesn't always turn
out for the best we need do the right
thing lots of times we stumble you know
and and your listeners may think that
the three of us you know I've always you
know been on the top of the heap but all
three of us have fallen short
I mean I'll tell you this languishing in
prison camp the first the first month in
that prison camp I laid there in in in
blood and sweat and tears and and and my
mental state was just in the tank
because I'd given up fighter pilots is
not supposed to give up
Jim and I weren't trained to serve enter
and and my mentalism but the depression
that I had just because of that and I
think that largely in life you know when
you do do the right thing and it doesn't
turn out right then you have to get up
dust yourself off get back in the back
in those in the fray and that's tough to
do you know the last thing you want to
do when when you're getting beat up
every from every side and you really
want to quit the last thing you want to
do is to is to stand up and be forceful
again to do you know to to take control
of the situation and yet it's those
kinds of challenges in life that build
that character you know that really make
the difference between you know that the
the the positive life the life lived
well and those guys and gals that they
don't make those kind of decisions and
you're talking about when you were when
you were depressed when you were laying
there it's because you felt like you had
failed right you felt like you had
broken you felt like you weren't the man
that you thought you were and that
they'd found your breaking point and
you'd found your breaking point and you
didn't like that him and what if I
remember correctly what what what got
you through that was you know you you
went broke down and to go on to your
Bonior cellmates and said well this is
horrible I'm I'm I'm a disaster I'm a
failure
I broke and he kind of said oh yeah
welcome to the club we all break it was
like one of those things and I think to
your point absolutely everyone everyone
has a point where they go I you know III
I failed to hear I
didn't do what I was supposed to do I
lacked the character that I needed at
that time to to be a good leader or to
even stand up and fight one more time I
failed and the point is us all sitting
around at this table and every single
person that's listening to this right
now you can find a spot in your life
where you said you know what I didn't do
it I didn't hold the line
I know my character broke and I wasn't
the person that I should have been at
that moment and that's that's absolutely
true but what's more important than the
fact then that we all get to a point
where we break is number one that
everybody breaks and number two that
doesn't mean it's over
that just means it's a bump in the road
it's a bump in the road and you got to
rebuild from it you got to come back and
you can you can do that and not only
that but largely that bump in the road
builds your character even further
because you understand your limitations
and you understand that you can overcome
these things and you know back to this
story of the prisoners of war 591 of us
came home and from that 591 men we
produced 17 generals and six admirals
and most of us retired as senior great
military officers we went back to flying
planes and commanding fleets and and
battalions all over the world we have a
bunch of congressmen two United States
senators vice presidential candidate
presidential candidate all from 591 guys
and and so and and we all felt like we'd
failed we all felt like we'd given up
but even because of that adversity you
know we came out stronger than ever
before yeah I think this really goes
also to the fact that I mean what you're
saying is essentially the fact that you
have to know you have to understand what
your weaknesses are you really do and
and you have to understand human beings
and what human beings weaknesses are and
for me you know and I've talked about
this a ton on this podcast you have to
understand that there's that human
beings are capable of doing very dark
and horrible things and if you can't and
if you can't recognize that you yourself
are capable of the dark and horrible
things and of the
weak things well then you're not really
being truthful with yourself and and
with your existence really as a human
being and you ignore those things and I
think when you ignore those things I
think that's when they sneak up on you I
think you're right you know I think
that's the crux of our real serious
challenge with suicide within the
veteran population and and I've worked
on this and Jim's worked on this Andy
and and you've worked on it as well
and what are the advantages we had as
prisoners of war is that we that we
exposed ourselves you know we recognize
our weakness and and to a man we knew
that we weren't as strong as we wanted
to be and so just just that community
that we built within the prison camp
tapping on walls and tugging on wires
and our secret codes very difficult to
communicate with everybody else but we
had leadership there that turned that
that that turned that whole thing around
and and the leadership had wait a minute
you're not a victim now I'm a very
junior officer there and I'm a
lieutenant j.g and wait a minute I'm in
a communist prison camp I am leading
them for open wounds I have no medical
care I'm starving I've been tortured I'm
down to 115 pounds and I'm not on the
defensive I'm not a victim yeah you pull
up your big boy pants let's get on with
this saying we got a war to fight
and and and so the leadership totally
reap the they refocused the whole
purpose of our being there and that and
gave us a mission and I think that's one
of the challenges we face when a guy
gets out of the military or a gal and
takes off that uniform he loses the
purpose he loses that mission and and it
uses losses that community and he puts
on a coat and tire you know puts on a
golf shirt and goes out and tries to
reconnect with people and a gym is what
you were talking about you know at being
in civilian clothes in Paris and you you
were looking for some way to reconnect
it with with your unit and I
chronically here they come marching down
the Champs Elysees the valley no and and
and and there you were back in uniform
and and and so you and and you had
wrestle and d'etre you know you had a
purpose a a reason to live just because
of the group that you were associated
with and and whenever I speak publicly I
you know I challenged an audience to if
you've got if you know a veteran you
know talk to them you know give them a
purpose you know invite them to in tear
into your house your club or your church
and it may make a difference and that
way you can serve your country by
serving those who served their country
yeah it's a it's interesting you know
Jim you kind of you kind of made that
joking comment you know hey Truman
dropped the bomb and ruined a perfectly
good war and we all laughed at it
but we also kind of understand that
there's some level of of reality to that
and you think when you're in the
military and I always you know I was I
was talking about the fact that when I
joined the Navy was nineteen ninety and
I just missed the first Gulf War and
like I was completely dismayed by that
because you know there hadn't been Oh a
war since basically since Vietnam so
it'd been 20 years and I'm thinking okay
there was there was my shot to fight in
a war and I just missed it
and and so that that what you're talking
about of hey do you feel like this is
your purpose and and this is what I'm
supposed to be doing with my life and
it's a higher purpose and it's a higher
cause and it's something that is is
bigger than you and so when you're a
part of it it feels good and you want to
participate you want to help and then
when it's over you look around and you
go wait a second what's my higher
purpose now and and I think you're right
that's where people get into trouble
because they're so tied to their old
higher purpose and they can't transition
to the new one and you know I get great
feedback from from vets all the time
that they do they open up they go okay
well what am I gonna do now that's so
that's what I'm looking at what's your
next mission gonna be yeah what is and
you know what your next mission might be
being a good dad
right that might be your next mission
you know what your next mission might be
it might
be building airplane hangars you know
hey you don't know what your next
mission is gonna be but find out what
your next mission is gonna be make it
something productive make it something
that's gonna impact you know at least
you and your family and get good at it
even if you pick something that's
somewhat selfish and you say hey I want
to I want to observe on every continent
okay that sounds like a good mission to
me actually that sounds like a really
good
I might have to participate in that one
but you know you come up with something
UK okay here's my mission and this is
what I'm gonna do with it and this is
how I'm gonna go forward but yeah I
think that the lack of purpose and the
lack of mission that guys stumble into
is problematic and it is problematic too
because in the military it's I don't
want to make this sound the wrong way
because I always talk about the fact
that for us we didn't get tasked
missions like when when when I was in
Iraq we there was no higher up telling
me you guys are gonna take this target
or you guys gonna take that that
happened occasionally probably less than
5% of the time most the time we
developed our own missions but overall
when you're in the military you have a
broad mission that you're trying to
accomplish which again is for societal
good and so when that disappears guess
what you have some autonomy now now what
are you gonna choose as your next
mission what are you gonna do how are
you going to improve yourself how you
improve your life your families your
communities or your countries or the
world what are you gonna do to make it
better and you see the vets that are out
there that are doing that
man they they go excel makes absolutely
you know when I was in the hospital at
Great Lakes after the war I was in a
hospital up there I'm you know I I
didn't have any serious problems but I
was in a debriefing thing and but I had
figured out in that hospital and even on
the way home that my my next stage of
life is I'm going to to try to forget
all that six years of in that prison
camp that six years of pain and I even
had it figured out I'm gonna go to some
little town in the middle of nowhere
where they've never heard of Charlie
plump but if they have I'll change my
name because I don't want anybody
knowing my history I want you know I
want to slide back into the shadows of
life and and I I was serious about that
you know my my height my high school
sweetheart had just
file for divorce three months before I
came home and and and so I was you know
I mean I felt free and I felt energized
but I really didn't want to have
anything to do with the Vietnam War or
any of the pain that I had faced there
saw no value in it and I was and so I
was the first guy back to the from the
war in the Midwest and so the news media
you know really wanted to talk to me and
so I found myself surrounded by about a
hundred and fifty photographers and
reporters in the basement of that
hospital and I told my story and on the
way back up to my hospital room just as
the elevator doors closed this young
reporter came up to me and I'm nose to
nose with this young guy but he's got
lines of anguish in his brow and tears
in his eyes and he said Mr plumb you
really got to me in there he said I've
had a miserable year my family's falling
apart my job is terrible he said I even
wondered if I wanted to go on living he
said you've given me hope well I hadn't
intended to give anybody any hope I'm
just telling my story here you know on
and it surprised me that there was some
value in the experience and so and and
so I said well if in fact that you know
the pain of that experience can help one
person you know in life then maybe there
is a purpose to it and so so I wrote a
book my autobiography and I started to
promote that book and and and I found
that yes there's there's a lot of
connection with people with challenges
and you don't have to be in the military
to have a challenge and and and while my
experience might have been a little more
dramatic you know than most and it's an
interesting statistic it's still you
know the the challenges I faced were the
challenges that you know that that a
single mother trying to make ends meet
makes you know the frustration and the
loneliness and the in the and the the
lack of confidence and the feeling that
you're not measuring up and you know all
these things these are these are common
human feelings you know what to be in a
prison
and to be in prison yeah no that's
that's a great but actually I was I was
cursed cuz I've never heard before about
the flak houses and that the Bombers the
but that bomber crews were being sent to
when they'd but when they basically said
all right we're we're done right now and
then what was the casualty rate of the
bomber crews it was something completely
insane wasn't it well it was they they
had a twenty five mission requirement
and the percentages said they couldn't
make it
now we're talking in early forty three
the start of the heavy bombing was late
42 so let me just let me just focus in
on that for one second just to explain
to everyone what that means because I I
did know about the twenty five so if you
were a bomber crew you were flying in in
what a b-17 b-17 the twenty four a b-17
or B 24 big giant Flying Fortresses and
they would get attacked ruthlessly
attacked and they'd fly deep into France
and on into Germany and they would get
swarmed and attacked by you know by
German fighter pilots and and also
anti-aircraft guns from the ground and
so it was it was hellish to get through
and it was so bad that they said okay
well all you have to do is this many
missions and the number was 25 which I
did know that number he had to make it
through 25 of these bomber ons and you
were done you you that was it you didn't
have to do anymore
but you're saying the chances of
actually making it through those 25 was
minimal the percentages were against you
now sure some people are going to get
through some people are going to be shot
down on their first mission they don't
get a second mission but and this was
the problem with the heavy bomber forces
in it and we almost lost that one I mean
we came close where we were at the
ragged edge and all I and I'm repeating
what I learned as a youngster at that
time trying to be an aviation cadet that
guys were hanging on by our fingertips
when you say we almost lost that one you
mean we almost
had to stop the bombing campaign well
the British were after us
they had switched tonight bombing for
this very same reason stay away from the
fighters mm-hmm and so our philosophy of
ever bombardment goes back to General
Mitchell in the in the early and 30s and
late 20s in fact the early twenties that
the Bombers will fight their way through
and that was the theory of the b-17 and
Josh knows they were heavily armed but
they're all they were up against the
determined enemy and they're 500 miles
from home and German fighters all they
gotta do step out they don't like what's
going on bail out they're coming to come
down and we'll go get another airplane
but those were dark days and they were
dark days until the first fighters the
beep the p-47s could only go so deep
right well could they go like 200 miles
deep at 200 200 miles yes and have
enough fuel to get home and the rest of
the times that bought the other 300 mile
round trip or 400 extra miles were all
the bombers by themselves imply if it
was 50 miles it was hell once the
fighters turned back so they sent four
they ended up with a with four groups of
p-38s and 38 was not ready to go to war
over what Germany at that time at the
altitude we were having trouble with the
airplane and we didn't have the latest
modifications to the airplane so the
part of our problem was engine problems
with the Allison engines but they went
anyway and so then the 51 came along
51 had a British engine who had which
had been developed in that very same
area and they you know they weren't
having the cold their engine had been
designed and operated
sixty degrees below zero and so they
they match the two up and so on late
forty three they get the first group
over there and now there's a little hope
the airplane could go the whole way the
thirty eight have been going to go the
whole way but thirty eight had been
modified for the Pacific there was no
heat in the cockpit and you're sitting
up there at sixty degrees below zero
freezing your tail off with the oxygen
the oxygen mass is actually frozen to
your face he came in you had one warm
spot in the whole comic octet and that
was your right foot it's not the heat
so everything else is freezing your
Fanny off and so and they had so we had
problems
luckily the the British engine the 51
and North Americans tremendous design
put together the airplane that could do
the job
the and then think of to cut the p-51s I
scored on the whole the whole dog goes
the whole way and then cruise around and
goes someplace else
Wow the 38 could do that it had the fuel
to do it but again you know there's an
old story about the 38 that kind of
broke our heart there was two great
modifications to the p38 the 38 at
altitude up with the bombers and they're
hit with fighters you can get into a
scrap and the German rolls over and they
had explained the flick role that I
encountered they do a flick role in
split s make a dive to the deck
if the 38 did that and tried to follow
him the airplane would accelerate into
what we call a compressibility and
compressibility was nothing more than a
shockwave off of the the the wing that
killed all the control in your Impa not
so you couldn't pull out so all you
could do is write it down until you got
into what we called fit air got the
then your trim tab if you said it
properly would gradually bring you out
of that dive before you hit the ground
some of you hit the ground so and we
didn't have we have a very slow rate of
roll in the 38 so they develop a neuron
boost so we could actually we could roll
with anybody they had the dive flap so
if you went in you could actually hit
the dive flap button put that airplane
straight down and dive with anybody in a
German fighter
so what Lockheed did they got 400 sets
shift sets of dive flaps and ailerons
boost they put it on an Air Force
transport plane and they sent it to
England it got intercepted off the
English coast by the RAF who didn't know
anything about it they thought it was a
German condor 400 never they shot it
down the way there goes all of our
movies and so what do you do now it took
quite a while to pull all those 400
units together and get them over there
so for the next couple months the 38 sar
doing the same old thing we don't have
the improvement p-51 comes along thank
God and it can do the job so it's all
history yeah 50 once had trouble we I
know of one that pulled out of a dive in
the whole damn engine fell out of the
airplane and the guys got killed but
they had engines quit single-engine
fighters that's the problem somebody
throws a rock at you and it hits the
radiator you're all done so but those
were trying times yeah I guess I was
with all that you know thinking about
these these guys that were in those
bomber crews that would need a break and
they say okay you need to go over here
not think about this and it reminds me
of you know talking about the you know
dick winners
from the first the 5:06 band of brothers
and what he would say when he would see
guys were getting stressed out you know
he'd get him off the line get him out of
it and and give them the rest that they
need and and then I think I think
there's a certain party that goes okay
like I need to not think about this
right now and then I think you got to
say okay now I'm gonna talk about this
and and the fact that you get around
your your friend and that's what a lot
of people that listen the podcast a lot
of veterans I listen the podcast they go
you know now you know I've had my break
but now you're talking about this stuff
and I appreciate it and I brinkmate lets
me know that I'm not the only guy that
thinks this way or had those thoughts or
you know went through this and I think
that's that's good so I think it's I
think you do need a break and actually
that now that I think about it when I
was in Ramadi I had I the book that I
read every night was about faced by
Colonel david hackworth and I read it
every single night every single night
every single night and then about three
months in the deployment III wanted to
guys I didn't want to think about you
know I don't want to go to bed thinking
about you know the war and war and and
so I there was a random book sitting
around and I picked up it was actually a
book called the electric kool-aid acid
test which is about the hippies in it's
written by Tom Wolfe who wrote the right
stuff sure but it's a great book and it
was so completely outside of what I was
doing that it gave me you know like a
mental break and I read that book and it
was you know it took me four days to
read that book and I got done and I put
it away I put pulled about face back out
and I continued on but I just needed a
little bit of a breather right just a
little bit of a mental breather and I
guess hippies in LSD provided me with
that reading about those hippies in LSD
provided me with this little mental
break and it was actually it's a fair
it's a very interesting book and it
shows the mentality that those people
had you know which was the way he summed
it up was was was me me me me
everything's about me and that was what
was good for me to read this book I'm
like okay that's not how I want to be
with with my life it's not about me it's
about you know what we're trying to do
here so yeah I think sometimes
need a mental break I I can't even
imagine what the you know what was going
on in one of those flak houses with
those guys that's not like an R&R for
you they were run by the Red Cross and I
was at Mulford Manor which was right on
the Thames River of course I was there
when we had the ice storms in fact when
I left the the plaque house
to go back to Paris I couldn't get a
ride across the channel and guess what
our friend Glenn Miller got a ride and
disappeared and so I'm trying to get
across the channel to Paris and it's
between Christmas and New Year's and I
wait I went out to several of the bases
around run London to get an ATC aircraft
to go to Paris and they're all grounded
and so I went down to Southampton and
two ships had just come into Southampton
that were going on to lahar and so I got
on board and they were hospital ships
with a complete complement of general
hospitals like two or three different
general hospitals and are full of nurses
and so New Year's Eve where we're on
this ship with all these nurses and
we're on I guess you'd call it battle
stations
because the ebo to the German e-boats
were operating in the channel and we're
going across from Southampton to lahar
and all these nervous nurses from the US
needed comfort
to get a medal for that anyway that was
that was the story not just how I got to
the end of this story I've forgotten
I picked up a couple things when we were
talking and when I got shot down you've
read this citation well I didn't know
anything about that citation I had
gotten my fanny shot off I was not happy
I said I kept thinking what could I have
done different that I could have stayed
in that fight longer and I never came up
with an answer what could I have done so
for about from September till I get this
orders to go to Paris the spots his
headquarters I was not the highest I
didn't think much of myself is why did
it why couldn't I have done a better job
but reading that citation and then
belonging to a group called the Legion
of Valor which there are not too many
Air Force guys left in it and I read
what these people have done these
grounds in fact one of my very close
friends and that had the Distinguished
Service Cross and they just operated it
to confess the Medal of Honor and he's
gotten quite a bit of publicity and he
was in Vietnam
and my comment when I saw that he had
gotten a Congressional Medal honor at
this late date I thought was God
somebody finally read his citation and
when you when you think that that what
all of these guys did a lot of the
fellows in the
the Legion of Valor our medics what they
did and combat conditions and got to
distinguish curves across the Navy Cross
and so forth it's you know I I read my
citation it took six minutes that's all
and then I read a book called I'm no
hero and I think
can I have Charlie pawn six years of
back my six minutes for me that's I mean
what he went through is just
unbelievable to me and so don't give me
the monk about I'm no hero
he's my but it's it's it's deep thought
well thanks for that Jim I appreciate
your saying that but let me cost one
more question that you Jocko because Jim
and I both talked about getting shot
down and feeling miserable after your
your fight where you accidentally killed
one of the Iraqi soldiers but you felt
pretty little about that yeah that's
about his that's about as bad as it gets
and you know it was a horrible situation
it was the fog of war it was multiple
units out on the battlefield it was it
was actually not not me that was that
that shot an Iraqi soldier it was one of
my small teams that was in a position
where you know amongst the confusion
they were assaulted by a friendly group
of Iraqi soldiers with one they had one
marine with them and yeah you know it's
it's it's something that you can it's
hard to make you know definite
statements or or or say I know this for
a fact but there's pretty much not
anything worse in war than friendly
forces killing friendly forces that just
that's just as bad as it gets and it's a
real taboo in in Special Operations for
sure it's a taboo at any and I'll tell
you during the
during the I guess we'll say the dry
years in between Vietnam and and the
current wars were in there was we
actually lost the understanding of how
these things could happen and and no one
really understood the fog of war anymore
and therefore we didn't train to it
properly and so when it happened
it was it was like an unbelievable thing
it was so bad it was the absolute worst
thing that a cab actually I would say
there would be one more thing you know
the salt the the person that was killed
the soldier that was killed was an Iraqi
soldier you know if it had been a seal
or an American I guess that would make
it one level higher for me because I
would have known the person you know in
this case it was an Iraqi soldier again
a tragic loss nonetheless but you know
how did I feel it felt it felt
absolutely horrible and the thing that
you know the thing that changed the
mindset for me was when I realized that
as I sat there and reviewed because you
know my commanding officer was coming to
inspect and and review what had happened
along with the investigating officer and
and you know the thing that changed my
mindset was as I sat there and said okay
whose fault is this whose fault is this
and I'm looking at all the different
mistakes that were made by all the
different units and all the different
people and as I'm looking to blame this
on someone it would became very clear to
me and like a bolt of lightning that
there was only one person in charge of
this and therefore there's only one
person responsible for what happens out
there and that's me and honestly the
when I had that transition in thought
and it was it was the first moment that
I've I felt actually okay mm-hm
there's a horrible sinking feeling that
you get in in in wartime situations I
guess you can get in another time sue
and I've talked about it with with some
of my friends it's like when something
is just really horrible is happening you
get this knot in your stomach and this
it's I've never felt at any other times
but when I was overseas
of like this is I I have it's it's the
hot most horrible feeling and that was
that was the most severe I ever felt it
was leading up to my own recognition
that you know what and and where that
was coming from was the unknown and I
didn't know how to react to it and here
I was you know mister experienced seal
mister you know in charge of the task
unit whatever and yet here I was going
how do I deal with this and I didn't
understand how to deal with it and what
I had to do is go to what I actually did
know which is if you're in a leadership
position you take responsibility for
what happens that's what you do so hey
that's what you do and if if they're
gonna fire you you get fired if they're
gonna reprimand you you get reprimanded
if they're gonna replace you with
someone else you get replaced you salute
you do the best turnover you can you try
and do the you know give all the
information you can that's what you do
and as soon as I accepted that and
looked at it and said ok well then that
not started to go away and I realized
that ok but the real problem here is is
you the way that you're looking at this
but and then the other big thing is once
you admit what those or and you take
ownership of those problems and you
actually not just take ownership of the
problems because you say here's the
problems and here's how we're gonna get
them solved here's the standard
operating procedures that were now going
to follow to make sure that this never
happens again
well then people look at you and they go
ok
he's got a plan he's not sitting here
dodging the the blame for this he's
actually taking ownership of the
problems and he's gonna get him solved
and I think you know I've never had this
conversation with my commanding officer
about his reaction but I could see it
you know I could see it and the fact
that I the fact that he said ok you know
let's make sure it doesn't happen again
I like the procedures that you're
putting in place use caution proceed you
know where is I believe that if I would
have said well it wasn't my fault it was
his fault and their fault the other
guy's fault he would have said ok you
need you're not gonna have this job
anymore and I think that's the same
thing with life you know the minute that
you're looking around you and you're
saying
hey it's someone else's fault that this
that I'm in this bad situation and again
you know what okay there's things that
happen I get that there's things that
happen to two people you mentioned one
of them you can get a disease that you
can't control you you know you can get
you can have a child get hit by a car be
there's awful things that can happen
that you can't have control over but
what you can't have control over is how
you proceed and how you go forward and
that's the part that you need to focus
on because the opportunity to fix what
happened in the past it's gone I'm sorry
there's no time machine there's no way
of going back it happened it's gone okay
how are you gonna move forward where are
you gonna go now that's what you need to
focus on and I've said that about regret
too people say oh you know I I live with
no regrets I'm like oh there's all kinds
of things I'll tell you I regret but I
don't walk around with them because I
can't do anything about them like you
know maybe you would have maneuvered
your aircraft a little bit different on
September 16 1944 you've looked at it
maybe you couldn't but maybe you could
have but you don't walk around carrying
that because it doesn't matter anymore
and it's the same thing with the things
I've been through it's like okay look
I've made mistakes you've made mistakes
we've all made mistakes okay what are we
gonna do are we gonna dwell on those I
let them you know bear down on us and
even things that we can't control maybe
the mistake wasn't ours something that
we couldn't control I'm not gonna carry
that I'm gonna I'm gonna not gonna carry
that regret I'm gonna say what what can
I do to move forward and actually
there's a great guy just had on the
podcast named Rob Jones he's a Marine he
fought in Iraq and in Afghanistan and he
ended up he was a he was a bomb disposal
digging for mines a combat engineer and
he ended up finding a mine
and he found that mine were you know
with his own feet and he he lost both of
his legs and he said something that was
was awesome he says you know you've got
this weight that's bearing down on you
and he was sitting in a hospital bed and
he had this weight that was bearing down
on him if he's gonna live now the rest
of his life with you know both legs
amputee amputated above the knee and he
you know he said what am I gonna do with
this wait am I gonna let it am I gonna
let it push me down
and bury me under the ground or am I
gonna use that weight to make myself
stronger and I think that's a incredible
attitude to have and and by the way he's
about to run thirty-one marathons in 31
days he's gonna run 31 marathons in 31
days yeah yeah unbelievable so you know
the toughest flying that I ever did was
in combat in support of the ground
troops and they'd bring us in with
rockets or bombs or napalm we didn't
have any guns on that airplane
and but we knew that we had to get close
but not too close to the to the
friendlies to be effective you know if
we couldn't put our weapons you know 40
klicks away and and do any good at all
but we get in too close to starts engine
the mustaches are those soldiers or
Marines down there and and and by the
way if you get too close actually it
goes way beyond singeing mustaches yeah
if you go too close you can kill
friendly troops and again we're about to
what we've just talked about so that's
that's a nightmare and it was done you
know I mean again the fog of war and
that's what happens and it's really
really unfortunate so I would get that
knot in my stomach when era I was called
in to support the ground troops in fact
would you know torch off this the smoke
signal and I'd look at the wind and
trying to figure out exactly how I can
get in there close and lots of times I
would go below the fragged pattern of
the bomb I was dropping just so I could
get more accuracy and and we all did
that you know we weren't supposed to but
you know an average bomb you know
500-pound bomb would have a frag pattern
of 2,400 feet above the ground that's
what you were flying through after you
dropped the bomb and we'd go below that
just to get more accuracy because we
knew that those guys were dependent on
us and more they were there were some
happy facts you know after we after we
would support those ground troops but it
was you know it was pretty scary stuff
but back to your point about blaming of
the people I had a coach early on
they're very losing
sorry to say but but he but he would he
told us this because we'd start you know
blaming other things for the problem you
know yeah we were away and we didn't you
know the things weren't right
somebody's we blame somebody for this
there's somebody that you know the refs
were calling bad calls and all this
stuff and he'd said you know I said the
difference in success and failure in
life is not the things around you it's
the choices you make about things around
you and you can blame everybody else for
your problems but in doing so you give
away control of your life and I think
that's the the accountability issue that
you're talking about you know is that
there's there's certainly freedom in
discipline there's also freedom in
accountability I think because when you
like you say you know what when you say
okay yeah lots of people made a lot of
mistakes but oh by the way I was in
charge and so you know the onus is
really on me and and I find that when I
when I practice taking when it practiced
taking responsibility for some of the
bad things that really weren't my fault
and I practice doing that it frees me up
I think tool it you know - for your life
yeah that's actually an interesting
point because sometimes people they they
hear like they'll read the book extreme
ownership that we wrote then they go
okay cool all I need to do is take
ownership of the problems and then I'm
then I'm a good guy yeah right they go
oh you know hey these mistakes happen
that's my fault
you know so let's get him fixed and it
actually doesn't work and actually and
and when I say hey there's all these
mistakes that were made on the
battlefield and different people made
actual mistakes they made mistakes
though the day we had that blue on blue
there were other people that made
mistakes
what I'm saying isn't like all those
before my mistakes hey it's my fault no
no what I'm saying is actually
truthfully those mistakes were things
that I should have foreseen that I
should have understood better that I
should have planned better that I should
have trained guys better for that they
they're they they made the mistake but
the root problem of that mistake is my
fall it's not just saying hey my boss
say it's it's you know oh yeah that was
my fault no no no and actually is my
fault man I have this conversation too
where people say well what if I do if
what do I do if I tell my employees Oh
guys it was my fault
and then my employees say yeah that's
right it was your fault and the people
don't know what to do
and I said well it is your fault that's
what I'm saying I'm not saying this so
that it makes people not look at you and
blame no no no when someone says if I
say charlie we screwed up this mission
it was my fault you go that's right it
was your fault I don't know no no I
don't know what your fault no no that's
not how it works
I say Charlie I was the commander this
mission I didn't give you enough
information I didn't Guiding review your
plan well enough I didn't give you the
training that you needed I didn't give
you the sport that you needed that was
my fault that is what and here is what
I'm gonna do to fix it so when I look at
you and say hey this is my fault that
this happened you say you're right it
was I go exactly these are the things
I'm gonna do to fix it here's work the
way we're gonna do this from now on
here's some procedures we're gonna put
in place so that this doesn't happen so
yes extreme ownership is not by any
stretch an escape hatch it's not in fact
when you take ownership you shut the
hatch and it's right there and you're
not getting out the only way to get out
is to find solutions for the problems
and move forward yeah so it's an
interesting it's interesting well that
brings me up to civilian life now you
talked about a mission and having
something out in front of you
well like I got off active duty in 1948
June exactly two years before Korea
started and my father-in-law who
actually became almost like a father to
me by that time we'd been married for
three years and he was deeply involved
in the paper industry he was president
of wax paper Western wax paper here in
Los Angeles he had sold the company to
crown Zellerbach and his best friend was
Richard McDonald who was this executive
vice president of crown Zellerbach
and between the two of them they defined
this little paper company and they're
going to take care of their son in laws
and son and so dick MacDonald got off
active duty as an engineer in the army
before before I did so he arrived at the
paper company maybe he almost a year
before I did and I had put my all the
money I had into this company before
while I was still on active duty so I
came home in June 48 and it's fourth of
July coming up and and my father-in-law
takes me down we buy three civilian
suits and all of a sudden I'm a civilian
and I'm gonna go work for this little
company and Dick MacDonald was running
the company because he was there a year
before but we had a partner in this
company and so I go down and I go to
work and bond because I'm mechanically
aligned it minded they put me in charge
of the operation the plant operation so
now I'm a civilian and I'm working hard
and it goes for about three months and
then I begin to notice that we get an
order in and we by that time we had
maybe 50 employees and we were making
paper napkins and shelf paper and all
these little items we were what was
called a paper converter and so I
noticed in running the plant that we'd
get an order in and I'd look at the
inventory and we'd had so much paper
back in the inventory and I go back and
check it and we ain't got it and so now
what's wrong and so we had a little
meeting and he decide well maybe we
better take an inventory and see what's
in the back of a plant there and it
turns out that our partner who actually
had control of the company was deathly
afraid to admit
that he had been losing money and he
wasn't dishonest or anything he just
didn't want to admit it and so to cover
the losses he inflated the inventory so
now we have this big meeting I'm ninety
days into being a civilian and we take
the inventory and we add all this up and
Dick McDonald and I Oh crown Zellerbach
corporation about twenty thousand
dollars its 1948 and let me tell you
twenty thousand dollars is one hell of a
lot of money and I mean this is when a
house would cost what five hundred to a
thousand dollars yeah Wow so so now what
do we do well the first thing we do is
well welcome to the business world we we
decide that we better do something and
our father and my father-in-law and
Richard McDonald's father said well what
are you gonna do well the first thing we
had to do is who had to go up and talk
to crown Zellerbach in San Francisco and
so in order to do that I had to buy a
top coat and a hat because you didn't go
to San Francisco on a business meeting
without having a hat and a top coat and
so we get on get on the train and we go
to San Francisco and we're plotting the
whole way up there up what are we gonna
tell him I have no idea and got off the
train at the station up there got a taxi
and we get down to the Sansom Street to
this big beautiful buildings this crown
Zellerbach and and I'm wearing my hat
and my new top coat and I'm going to see
mr. Zellerbach himself and just as I
walked in the front door some goddamn
pinching up above let's go
right down across my brain now the world
that the world can't be any worse no
what do i well we had our meeting with
mr. Zellerbach and he was very very
gracious he's all he said was what are
you gonna pay us the twenty thousand
dollars so he said well we're gonna work
on it and we did and we worked very hard
for about two years and we finally began
to make some money getting ahead and
Korea started 25th of June and about a
week later this fellow walks into our
office and he said we have a problem the
UMP from the US government and he said
you know we have we have to build up our
supplies and one thing that we just
can't seem to solve is toilet tissue for
k-rations
little pack of toilet tissue for the
little piece of paper around it - and so
he said we got one machine that belongs
to one of the paper companies and he
said we got that machine working 24
hours a day seven days a week and we're
not getting enough toilet tissue into
these k-rations what can you do I don't
know how in the heck he found us but
anyway he did so we thought well we took
a look at it and we figured that we
could go to crown Zellerbach and get in
her fold tissue paper and you could sit
down and you could flick 20 sheets of
inner fold make two folds in it and then
we had to have a tube and so our
superintendent and I went out and we
bought a nickel a little machine and
made a nickel pack for a dollars worth
of nickels the tube 20 nickel
we made the tube and we cut it in half
now we got a tube to put two twenty
sheets in and so I sit down for about an
hour and I folded paper and they time me
and they figured that because rough as I
am why if I can do it that much in an
hour then a young lady could do it so we
hired about fifty gals and we put put
them to work and I'm making these little
toilet tissue wraps and putting the tube
on it and throw it in a box and we put
them on piecework and they were doing
very well in fact we were out producing
Scott tissues machine almost immediately
and these little gals down in East Los
Angeles for making more money than
anybody else in East Los and piece work
and so everything's going great we're
making money we're paying off the
balance of the twenty thousand dollars
we owe two years later and that guy
walks into the office he came into my
office says you know he said if you got
a situation here
he had some of my packs and he
said said I'd like to see your operation
so we took him out and plant and she
picked up some of these tubes and he
looked at him took him apart kind of the
tissues in front of me and they were all
perfect and he said I got something to
show you and he pulls these little notes
out and he said just read them and
here's his little note written at
handwriting in this tube and these young
ladies have been writing these little
notes and putting him inside the the two
of the tissue and they left nothing to
your imagination
[Laughter]
this they said can you imagine some GI
in a foxhole in the rain taking this
apart and reading this note how's he
gonna feel why don't we just leave it
alone it's not talking let him keep on
doing it it has to be a morale builder
anyway that's how we paid off the 25
believe me that two years of trying to
pay that off that military training that
I had really was very helpful
it must be a museum somewhere that's
looking for those two you know I have
one value it's not it's not an original
somebody picked it up after it must have
been for Vietnam they they were they
picked it up and were producing and so I
just I have one of my desk
this is a reminder you know having a
mission I got a mission real quick and
it's it was a very discouraging one to
think of owing $20,000 and that was well
over twice what I paid for my house I
just looked at my watch we've been going
for about two hours and 45 minutes I
think we wrap up this run echo you got
anything else have you said anything
today no okay do you have anything to
add yeah I do um when I lived in
Honolulu I had a motor scooter as well
really crashed it didn't break my leg
yeah they can get you you yeah yeah you
feel so like free with it and you want
to do stunts and yeah yeah be careful oh
yeah yeah go everywhere
yeah yeah well yeah and that that's it
thank you both very very much
oh hey glad to be with you Charlie plum
sir anything else you want to you want
to say and I think we've covered it all
really great being with you guys you
know I think that the the transfer of
our not necessarily our knowledge but
our war stories but just the philosophy
you know that we're coming up with
because it it spans the test of time I
think and will continue just expand the
test of time you know the accountability
issue there face your fears issue the
making choices issue the review no
refusal to blame other people for your
problems you know take take control of
your life and it's just not just a
military thing and I think it's true
with with our kids and that's true with
students and politicians and all all
manners of our society just I think
needs a a little shot you know of
accountability agree Oh aye degrees
without and I think that you know
meeting Charlie and what a wonderful
spokesperson he is he's actually gotten
me into a position that I had to talk in
front of the crowd a few times and I
always try to get in first because I I
don't want to follow so well well
they're captive I want to talk to him
but I would love to be able to reach
some of the edge you are doing reach
some of these young people who not that
they're just because they're not
thinking the way I think but I think
they're losing something they're losing
something that this great country has
given to an awful lot of people and i i
i feel that i'd like to beat something i
can't and i think you're reaching him I
think Charlie's reaching him giving you
a URI
but there's so much we could say and my
granddaughter just graduated from the
University of Michigan for years and
it's pretty liberal school and we we pay
a lot of money and our send our kids to
school and sometimes they they get
something wrong thoughts and at least I
think they're wrong maybe they're not
maybe they're right
but I don't think so and so I think the
work you're doing and Charlie's doing
and the three of you are doing is so so
important
for the future well obviously thank you
for coming for coming on the show both
of you it's it's such an honor to be
sitting here with you guys
and and also we wouldn't be sitting here
if it wasn't you know for men like you
that stood up and and fought and that's
why we're here and that's why we have
the freedom to be here to do this and
the freedom to try and pass that
information on so people understand what
kind of sacrifices were made so that we
can live in this amazing country with
this incredible amount of opportunity to
do just about anything you want
and whether that's take care of your
family or go out and build some kind of
a corporate empire you can do it here
and you can be happy in any one of those
categories and it's amazing so thank you
for coming on and again I think if it
wasn't for generations of men like you
answering the call to fight then our
great nation would have perished long
ago and it would have perished to
tyranny and it would have perished to
darkness but because of you and men like
you we do live in freedom and we provide
hope and light to the world so thank you
both for giving that to us
so we wrapped up with Charlie plum and
with Jim Conkel in in the hangers I got
a little off track at the end there I
know that we were going to mention at
least some social media and Charlie
poems information I failed to do that
we're now back in the studio to do that
right now so if anybody wants to link up
with captain Charlie plum you can find
him on Twitter he is at Captain capped
plum plum so Capt PL UMB that's on
Twitter
he's also Charlie plum on Facebook or
you can go to Charlie plum comm if you
want to get in touch with him also if
you do want to find either myself or
echo Charles you can find us also on
Twitter on Instagram and also on the
facebook you can find us there EKKO is
at echo Charles and I am at Jocko
willing and if you want to support this
podcast in any way echo how can we do
that anyways I'll keep this brief try to
forge in or gin main comm main the state
so Origin main comm good stuff gear all
made in America from the cotton the
actual raw cotton to the material to
make it all the way into what shirts
pants geez geez their flagship kind of
fraction yes yeah that's the origin of
origin is to make jujitsu G's in America
yeah but now we're making all kinds of
all kinds of cool stuff anyway yeah good
website check those ones up compression
gear also yeah now just rash guards yeah
compare compression gear are we calling
the rash guards compression
you were gonna have to figure that one
out yeah compression gear sort of sounds
all technical rash guards sort of the
reality the scenario in the surfing
situation yeah yeah
so both whatever you like know what we
mean yeah you know what we're coming
from on that one ultimately yeah yeah
also super krill
that's Jocko Supergirl krill oil mm-hmm
that's out you know
origin mean and then you click on labs
right there a lab they have to have when
they got a little bar you'll see it yeah
go there go to origin be calm and then a
bunch of people pre-ordered it ordered
it so what they should start oh it's in
the mail they're getting it people have
it now oh dang ok yeah they and yeah if
you want more you can get it there yeah
and joint warfare that's a good one too
so if you got this blend you got that by
the double you know situation that's
ultimately the kit right the joint
maintenance excellence kit that's it
yeah boom and then yeah like I said geez
rash guards all kinds of cool stuff just
going there and that's a that's a good
way to support also fitness gear
kettlebells you know how like you
mention this and I posted a little
Instagram video of me oh boy
you know you said all random yeah I'm
walking through this all that Instagram
that was a I'll give you credit yeah
that was a very good Instagram video
that actually that is exactly what that
was it was when you said yeah I keep my
just do a snatch yeah I just do a clean
in there clean a drink yeah so that's
what it was you know you walk by it you
notice it boom hit it yeah that thing
was calling you out you know but I will
admit now that I have like the whole set
pretty much chimp
werewolf gorilla 72 pumps big foot 90
pounds they're all out there right you
know right where you where I made that
video I feel the same way as you when I
walk by you just you kind of want to and
that's good for you yeah unless you're
all super cold and stiff and then you
want to grab the did 90 poem that's not
good go little lighter yeah yeah
yes anyway point there being I digress
anyway I get my kettle bells from on it
so kettle bells are cool of course I'm
not gonna go into a whole kettle bell
thing no I'm not gonna but if you want
the cooler kettle bells that kettle
bells the artistic ones I like the on at
once
proved werewolf one I think is my
favorite one don't you can get the
regular ones too anyway also a bunch of
other stuff maces battle ropes like any
kind of kind of the functional train is
it's functional stuff functional yeah
it's functional and it I guess the word
is fitness even though I don't like that
word that's that's why I was kind of a
functional training I guess hardcore
functional training yeah there is some
cool stuff on there and all the info
behind it you know on it calm slash
chuckle that's a good way to support
also when you buy a books including but
not limited to Charlie plums book
Jacques book go to the website Charlie
plums book is called I'm no hero right
yeah that's what it's called I'm not a
hero I'm no hero anyway go to jakku
podcast.com yeah for that book I
actually get it from Charlie Charlie
plum calm okay that's the best place to
get that book okay
actually you know what I'm gonna link it
to Charlie plum ya want it on your
website
yeah it's good idea so nonetheless go to
Java podcast.com go to the book section
boom click through there when you get
your books it's a good way to support
brings you to Amazon and could you do
something you sure could like it look as
in duct tape ear earphones Sarah
Armstrong bought something big I forget
what a lot more lot dollars you need a
lawnmower
definitely quickly before generator
support very good way also subscribe to
the podcast on iTunes teacher Google
Play and all other podcast providing
platforms seems obvious but hey that's a
good way also on YouTube
put some excerpts on there put one out
the other day mmm-hmm good one very
shareable but
less no less subscribe to the YouTube
that's a good way to support you get
other stuff on top of the video version
of this podcast excerpts and how should
I say other creative short films yeah by
one echo Charles sure with people that
we know acting in them yes sometimes but
yeah some value there anyway yeah
YouTube subscribe to YouTube that's a
good way also
Jaakko as a store it's called chuckles
door chuckle store calm there are some
good shirts on there literally literally
I'm sure this is good backwards anyway
um I'm not saying to buy something just
go in there check out stuff if you like
the stuff on there get something this is
stuff for women shirts patches rash
guards hoodies any day now the hoodies
are no more they're heavier donuts and
heaviest there well here's the thing
about the heaviest so I'm going through
the options you know how there's one
that's like too heavy and it's like
super never been the mission they're
like you've never been to Maine yeah
well I guess you have been amazed well
it wasn't that cool yeah no I get it
put it this way I'm convinced for
whatever that's worth
I'm convinced this is the appropriate
one okay that's right well we meaning
everyone that listens to this and myself
we will be the judge of that especially
people that are from the north of
America yeah or Canada sure the northern
read right go yeah I got you and I'm
confident
Ashland yeah just give me the feedback
all good we will also psychological
warfare on your journey slash campaign
against weakness if you run into those
days where you're not feeling like it
and that's affecting you where you're
led to make or potentially make the
decision to slack hit the snooze skip
the workout cheat on the diet
procrastinate
more or other forms of weakness you
listen to this album with tracks Jocko
tracks telling you pragmatically why you
shouldn't give in to those weaknesses
results do not vary 100% success rate on
that one in my experience psychological
warfare on iTunes Amazon music anywhere
where they sell mp3 it's a good one
very effective good way to support as
well also on Amazon
Jaco white tea you can get that through
Amazon you just search Jocko white tea
and then you order it and then you drink
it and you start throwing things around
and smashing everything around you
that's what it does no big deal be
prepared do have some books there too
you can get them way the warrior kid
that's a kids book extreme ownership
that's a book about leadership
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
that comes out October 17th its it's a
book about getting after it for lack of
a better word now what's interesting
about this is the book is the book is
not going to be available through
audible itself it's going to be
available through mp3 platforms such as
iTunes Google Play
what other platforms are there Amazon
Prime music so that's what's gonna be
available the reason we did that is that
the beats that we could instead of just
make it a big long multi our drone of
the talking its caught up as an album
with tracks which seems to be the way
that way you can utilize it for just
quick listening for almost like you'd
use psychological warfare album
yeah and it's a manual that's why right
yeah like this no it's not a story
that's not a story you know it's not a
story
yeah there's riggles warfare I mean
discipline goes freedom feel
is not a story mm-hmm it's a Field
Manual
its instructions so you can get that
there for your business
national on Front leadership me Lafe
babban JP Danelle Dave Burke if you want
to get tied into that if you want us to
come out and work with your company info
at national on front comm so that is
that those are all great ways to support
this podcast we appreciate it and thanks
to everyone for your support and mostly
for listening to the podcast especially
those that are out there in uniform that
provide the freedom and protection that
we will never take for granted freedom
that men like Charlie plum and Jim
Conkle fought and sacrificed to uphold
for us and I would simply ask everyone
to make something out of the freedom
that you have don't waste it
in the way that you get the most out of
your freedom I'll tell you that what way
that is the way you get the most out of
your freedom is discipline that's how
you get the most out of your freedom
push yourself hard get things done
create and build and make yourself the
best you that you can in everything that
you do but getting out there and getting
after it so until next time this was mr.
Jim kunkel captain Charlie plumb and
echo and Jocko out